TO THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HATE CRIMES AND
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE JOINT OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON THE PROGRESS OF
ADDRESSING HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE I KNOW SOME OLD
YOU'LL TROUBLED DISTANCE FROM
LOS ANGELES CA AND GOING TO
THINK YOU'RE VERY MUCH. TO
ENSURE SURE ALL THE ASSEMBLY SO
I'M MEDIA ON A CAR. TODAY I AM
VERY. HAPPY TO PARTNERING WITH
ASSEMBLY RULE YOU SOLD US WHO'S
THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT. HE FOR THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING. OF I
ESTABLISH THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HATE CRIME IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. I WAS SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RAPID RISE
OF HATE CRIME THROUGH ALL STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE PURPOSE OF
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON HATE CRIMES IS TO SERVE AS A
TOOL TO FOSTER TO. ENGAGE IN
OPEN DIALOGUE AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN BETWEEN ELECTED OFFICE
SHOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE PUBLIC.
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MY COLLIE AND NIGHT
REQUESTED A STAY WHY ALL THAT-
HEY CRYING IN ORDER TO GET A
FULL PICTURE OF HOW HOW HATE
CRIMES ARE BEING REPORTED.
INVESTIGATED AN ADDRESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND GOV
THANK FOR OURS A STATE OF HER.
OWN THE AND THE TEAM DID OF
WATER FOR JOBS AND THE
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENT.
NOW THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
BELIEVE THIS IS THE RIGHT TIME
TO FOLLOW UP. AND WHAT BEEN
DONE THINGS HE'S OF THOSE THAT.
END TO SEE WHAT MORE CAN WE DO
TO ADDRESS TO HATE CRIME IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATION I THINK THEIR
PARTS- ADDRESSING TO DEAL JADE
OR ADDRESS TO THE- LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND YOU'RE ALL.
SOME RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
POST THE WORLD YOUR THE- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF BILLS-
RECOMMENDATION FROM- A
REGISTERING PUSHED UP. OF
SPEAKERS THIS OF IN THE MORNING.
SO BAR AND WILL LEAD TO GIVE
THE OPERA FOR MY OF LOCAL SHARE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO LAST TO
HAPPENOPENING REMARKS ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIMILAR MEMBER CHIU FOR YOUR
DIGITAL LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC IT WAS NEARLY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO WHEN THESE
TWO COMMITTEES SELECT COMMITTEE
ON HATE CRIMES IN THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
CONVENE AN OVERSIGHT HEARING.
TO ROUTE TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT ON RAIMES- BACK THEN
DATA REPORTS CONSISTENTLY SHOW
THAT HATE CRIMES WERE ON THE
RISE IN CALIFORNIA. THE MOST
CURRENT DATA FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SHOWS A TWO POINT 5% DIP IN
HATE CRIMES. FROM
1-000-932-0172 ONE THOUSAND
SIXTY SIX. INCIDENCES IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. ALL THIS ALTHOUGH
THIS OVERALL TREND IS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THE NUMBER OF
EVENTS IS STILL TOO HIGH. THE
MOST.
UNDERMINE OUR DIVERSE
STATE IN IMPACT ALL OF US TODAY
I AM VERY INTERESTED IN HEARING
ANY ADDITIONAL UPDATES IN THE
REPORTED THE CRIME DATA AND
TRENDS IN HOW OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY IS
WORKING TO PREVENT DENTAL BY
AND BONTA ã CRIMES I ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO A CONSTRUCTIVE
DISCUSSION ON HOW THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HELP. ENSURE
THE RIGHTS BECAUSE WALK INS
REGARDLESS THIS. LEGEND AND
SEXUAL PREFERENCE ORIENTATION
THANK YOU AGAIN MR CHIU FOR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA I LOOK FORWARD TO TODAY'S
REMARKS. OF THEM VERY VERY ALSO
HAPPY TO BE JOINED BY AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM CHOI AND
COOPER. ANYONE OF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENT. PLEASE THANK YOU WANT
THANK YOU FOR A- COMMUTING
THIS- MEETING AND THANK
EVERYONE FOR ATTENDANCE HERE
OTHER MANY PROBLEMATIC ISSUES
WITH IDENTIFYING CLASSIFYING
TRACKING ME THE PROSECUTING
HATE CRIMES WITH THESE PROBLEMS
AND COUPLED WITH ALL TYPES OF
HATE CRIMES ON THE RISE THE
PORTS OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
PARAMOUNT. THIS IS THE ONLY
PROBLEM I SEE WITH CRIMES.
THERE SOME OF THE MOST
IMPACTFUL EVENTS IN DRIVE FEAR.
IN THE COMMITTEES A COLOR LGBT
Q. THESE IT INCREASING INSTANCE
OF HATE CRIMES HAVE EVEN
TRANSCEND POLITICAL AND
IDEOLOGICAL BELIEFS. THE FEAR
THAT HATE CRIMES IMPOSE ON
PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES CAN BE
LIKENED TO ACTS OF TERRORISM.
AND YET IN CALIFORNIA HATE
CRIMES NOT CONSIDERED OTHER
CRIMES WHAT'S THAT AGAIN IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY RIGHT NOW HATE
CRIMES NOT CONSIDERED VIOLENT
CRIMES. WHEN A PERSON IS
ACTUALLY CONVICTED AND SENT TO
PRISON FOR ACTS OF HATE CRIME
THEY'RE NOT CONSIDER CRIMINAL.
CALIFORNIA LAW. THIS MEANS THAT
THESE PERSONS ARE ELIGIBLE TO
HEATHER SINCE IS REDUCED TO THE
VERY BARE MINIMUM BY BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE.
THINK ABOUT THAT. THE FEAR IN
VIOLENCE OR EVEN FEAR OF
VIOLENCE A PERPETRATOR OF A
HATE CRIME OR MULTIPLE ACTS OF
HATE CRIMES. BECAUSE THE PEOPLE.
TRYING TO LIVE THEIR LIVES
PEACEFULLY IS NOT CONSIDERED
VIOLENT. THIS MUST CHANGE NOW
THAT'S IS COMMITTED TO ADD ON
TO THAT DISCUSSION GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT- THIS SAID JOIN
OVERSIGHT HEARING IS OCCURRING-
IT IT IT OCCURS IN THE CONTEXT
OF A- MULTI PRONGED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING HATE TO NOT JUST
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IT'S A AND IMPORTANT FOR US TO
DISCUSS WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT BUT THERE'S A
MUCH LARGER CONTEXT- AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD
WHERE HATE CRIMES ARE ON THE
RISE. WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
TO. HATE SPEECH FREQUENTLY-
LATER MANIFESTS ITSELF AS
VIOLENCE AND DO A WE SEE
EVIDENCE OF THAT- ON AN ALL TO
REGULAR BASIS SAID- IN OUR IN
OUR WORLD TODAY AND SO PANEL
DISCUSSIONS LIKE THIS AND
RECEIVING INFORMATION ANALYZING
IT TRYING TO TAKE ACTION-
BECOMES. A MUCH MORE COMPELLING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOWN
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HOSTING A HEARING THEMSELVES-
I'LL OF LATER OF LAST YEAR AND
OCTOBER. OCTOBER OR NOVEMBER
YOU HAD A HEARING. OCTOBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI. NO COST
ANY COMMENT. I BELIEVE THIS IS
A VERY SENSITIVE AREA- WE ALL
KNOW THAT- UNFORTUNATELY OUR
HUMAN REYES SO BASED UPON
WHATEVER DIFFERENCES- OUR WAY
SAY EXCEEDED THE- DISLIKES-
AND- YOU EVENTUALLY IN A
HATEFUL ACT SO. AND THEY MAY BE
ENTITLED TO HAVE THEIR OPINIONS
ABOUT- EXHIBITING AND THE TAKEN
ACTION. AS A FOLDER OF CRIMES
THAT THAT IS A DIFFERENT MATTER
SO IN THE COUNTRY OF- OUR-
DIFFERENT RACES- AND THE MIXED
UP. HI RUN SO THE MORAL OF THE
WORD I THINK WE NEED TO-
ENHANCE AT THE END OF SUCH
IMPORTANCE FACTOR. TO HEAR. THE
FAXES THAT UP NOT HAS FROM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO LESS WAS ALL PANEL
ALIKE WHO WERE INTRODUCE
PROFESSOR BRIAN LEVIN AS FOR
AND- OR- AUDITOR'S ELAINE
HOWELL AND ALSO HER STAFF
SENIOR STAFF- ERR ON THE FILTER
AND DEAR OF BIOS ARE IN YOUR
HAND ALSO NOT GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE EXTENT OF THE-
READING OF THEIR BIO BOOK FOR
YOU. AND A WE WILL STROLL WAS
OUT WITH HER SPEAKER WHICH
PROVIDES PROFESSOR LEVINE WE
ARE FOR A PRESENTER. AT HIS IS
A CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY
PROFESSOR AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND DID DIRECTOR OF CENTER FOR
THE STUDY OF HATE. AND
EXTREMISM A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SAN BERNARDINO
PROFESSOR. CHAIRMAN TO CHEER
SALAS. ASSEMBLY PERSON WILL. IS
THE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRIVILEGE OF COMING HERE
WITH SOME OF OUR LATEST- DATA
AND SUGGESTIONS- AS A PROPONENT
WHO APPEARED BEFORE THIS BODY
THREE YEARS AGO- TO VIGOROUSLY
SUPPORT A COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT
OF RESPONSE TO HATE CRIME IN
CALIFORNIA- WE TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE'RE GOING TO
PRESENT TO YOU SOME OF THE
EMERGING TRENDS. SOME
SUGGESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO THE
WELL DOT ORDER. INDEED URGING
OTHER STATE TO DO THE EXACT
SAME THING. ARM TRIMS IN
CALIFORNIA LOOSELY FOLLOW
NATIONAL CHANGES WITH SOME
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES FIRST
CALIFORNIA LIKE THE NATION HAS
SEEN A CLEAR UPWARD TREND OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. A DECLINE
LITTLE BIT OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS AS WELL THOUGH AND THIS
IS WHAT I THINK WOULDN'T GETS
LOST IN THE HEADLINES. AS WELL
AS AN INCREASE IN THE SALT.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT TOO EVEN THOUGH WE HAD
A DIP ASSAULTS- WE WERE TO
RECORD- WORKS JUNIOR DECADE
HIGH- WE'VE ALSO SEEN WE
SHUFFLING AS TO WHO'S WHO'S
GETTING ATTACKED. BOTH
NATIONALLY AND IN CALIFORNIA ON
ANTI MUSLIM HE CRIME IN
PARTICULAR ANTI MUSLIM ASSAULT
ON HEAD AND SHOULDER TOP AROUND
TWENTY SIXTEEN- BUT SINCE THEN
ANTI MUSLIM HATE CRIMES. HAS
DECLINED COUSIN TO CLIMB TO
LEVELS BELOW WHERE IT WAS A FEW
YEARS AGO SO WE'RE IN THIS
INTEREST CHANNEL THAT WAY
NATIONALLY WE AN ARM AN
EXPLOSION REGARD TO XENOPHOBIC
BUT- TYPE YOU KNOW. PRIME SCENE.
AT HEARING IN IN NOW TWENTY WAS
THIRTY PER OF THE F. B. I.'S
RECORD LOW TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
27% BELOW TWO THOUSAND ONES
RECORDS WERE KIND OF LIKE RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE CALIFORNIA HIT A
RECORD IN TWO THOUSAND ONE. ALL
OF OVER TWO THOUSAND HATE
CRIMES AND IN IN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS A SAYS SLIGHTLY
MORE THAN HALF THAT LEVEL. SOME
INTERESTING .COM IS GOING ON
THOUGH- NOT JUST WITH REGARD TO
GROUPS BUT GEOGRAPHY IF YOU
WANT TO LOOK AT HATE CRIME YOU
CAN'T LOOK AT IT LIKE- SOME
BROAD NATIONAL THING. IN TOTO.
THE WEATHER- IT'S INFLUENCED BY
A LOT OF BY LOCAL AND REGIONAL
A CONDITION TO CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST CITY LOS ANGELES. ONE
OF THE REST OF THE NATION'S
THREE LARGEST SIX. HIT HARD IN
TWENTY NINETEEN NOT SEEN SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE CENTURY
FOR LA. B. R. TWO THOUSAND TWO
CHICAGO NEW YORK AND WE TWO
THOUSAND ONE. BUT MANY SMALLER
STE. ANTI EIGHT. WE BELIEVE THE
IS DRIVEN INTO PART BY
AUTHORIZED IN SEMITIC HATE
CRIMES WHICH WERE THE TOP
CATEGORY IN THE NATION'S THREE
LARGEST CITIES LAST YEAR SO WE
HADN'T SEEN CERTAINLY IN RECENT
MEMORY AGAIN IN CALIFORNIA OVER
THE LAST TEN. YEARS ENDING
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HATE CRIMES
DECREASED SLIGHTLY- BY 3% BUT
THAT'S STILL 40% ABOVE LOS YOU
HAVE TWENTY FOURTEEN- AND AGAIN
NATIONALLY HATE CRIMES DROPPED
BY FOR MORE OVER THAT PERIOD BY
EIGHT POINT 5% BUT AGAIN
ASSAULT OR OR OR UP IN THE
STATE AT A DECADE HIGH UP TO
FIVE TWENTY FIVE AND THAT'S-
WELL. MORE WE WERE IN THE NINE
TWO SHE EVEN WHEN HE GET A FOR.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF ALL THE PROP
CRIMES DECLINING I THINK A LOT
OF THAT HEAT WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN DONE BY. INFORMAL
ASSOCIATIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE NOT BEING SPEWED ONLINE-
WE'VE SEEN A BIT OF AN INCREASE
THERE. NATIONALLY PERSON
DIRECTED HATE CRIME WHICH
INCLUDES THREATS AND ASSAULT I
HIT ITS HIGHEST LEVEL IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS WELL- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWO- SO UP. OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS A NATIONALLY WE
STILL OF THE TWENTY SEVEN
PERCENT- INCREASE IN THESE
PERSON DIRECTED CRIMES COMPARED
TO A 20% INCREASE OVERALL- AND
I HAVE MORE DATA BUT WE- FIVE
BECAUSE LIMITED TIME WE WON'T
GO INTO THAT BUT I DO THINK
THAT. CHAIR SALAS UP BROUGHT UP
OF A VERY IMPORTANT AN
INTERESTING TREND. ARM WHILE
AFRICAN AMERICANS BOTH
NATIONALLY IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR ITS STILL THE
NUMBER ONE GROUP ATTACKED. WE
SEEM DECLINE IN THE PROPORTION
I AM INDEED FROM NINETEEN
NINETY SIX NATIONALLY. FORTY
TWO PER CENT OF ALL HE CRIMES
THAT YEAR WERE AGAINST AFRICAN.
TWENTY TWO WE WERE DOWN TO. 27%
TO A BIG DROP THAT WAY BUT WE
SEE A BIT OF A DEMOCRATIZATION
OF HATE SO FOR INSTANCE WITH
REGARD TO JEWS TO DISABLE TRANS
GENDER GAY PEOPLE WE'RE SEEING
EVERYBODY- AGAIN AND LATINOS
IMPORTS PLEASE WELL ATTACK
THOSE THOSE FOLKS. UP
INTERESTINGLY AS WELL THOUGH ON
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORTS
SHOW THAT THEY WERE ABOUT I
THINK SIXTEEN COUNTIES REPORTED
ZERO EIGHT CRIME. AND AGAIN-
NATIONALLY- WE HAVE ABOUT 88%
THAT. EITHER SAY ZERO HATE
CRIMES OCCURRED OR OR THE THEY
JUST DIDN'T TURN IN THEIR FORMS
MOREOVER I THINK WE HAVE
SOMETHING ELSE THAT THAT WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON AS WELL AND
THAT IS EXTREMIST HOMICIDES OR
DATE ON EXTREMIST HOMICIDES A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE
AG COUNTY WHEN THEY COUNTED.
ZERO ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
ACTUALLY COUNTED THREE WHICH IS
WAS ON THE HIGHER END OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE PAST DECADE
NOT BECAUSE THE AG DO ANYTHING
WRONG THAT INFORMATION CAME
OUT. AFTER ARREST AND DURING
THE INVESTIGATION AND- JUST
BEFORE. TRIAL BOB PUT. WE SAW A-
OR DELAY FEW. IN EXTREMIST
HOMICIDES NATIONALLY UNTIL.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THIS IS THE
LATEST DATA WE COUNTED AT LEAST
TWENTY SIX WHITE SUPREMACIST
MOTIVATED HOMICIDES. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. DEBT THAT AMOUNT THAT
TWENTY SIX IS MORE THAN ALL THE
EXTRAS HOMICIDES COMBINED FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THIS YEAR
SIMILARLY. NINE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ACCOUNTED FOR THEM A RECORD NOW
THEY DIDN'T COUNT THE POLLS
NIGHTCLUB SO THERE'S SOME FLAWS
IN HOW THEY COUNT STUFF BUT
THEY'RE COUNTING A RECORD TO
WITH REGARD TO HATE HOMICIDES
AND CAME VERY CLOSE TO MATCHING
BUT- WHAT WE FOUND. OUT TWENTY
NINETEEN WILL BE A RECORD- JOSH
BECAUSE OF EL PASO AND INDEED
WE ARE NOW SEEING. LISTEN TO
THIS THE WORST MASSACRE LAST
YEAR. WAS A HEAT RELATED
MASSACRE. THAT'S SOMETHING. ARM
PREVIOUSLY I IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE FBI COUNTY TWENTY SEVEN
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENTS AND I
AM THE GREATEST NUMBER OF A
TELEPHONE THAT WAS THE PARK
LAND- SHOOTING ANOTHER THING I
THINK WE HAVE TO CONSIDER JUST
BASED ON ON DETAIL TRYING TO GO
THROUGH THIS REAL QUICK IS IT
MONSTER AROUND ACTUAL ELECTION.
OVER THE LAST DECADE WITH THE
WORST CASE NATIONALLY OFFER HE
CRIME AND WE'RE COMING INTO A
VERY CONFLICT WILL TIME
POLITICALLY WITH BOTH
IMPEACHMENT END OF A NATIONAL
ELECTION COMING UP TO PUT THAT
IN PERSPECTIVE. SIX MATCHING
WAS THE WORST MONTH FOR HATE
CRIME- GOING BACK TO JUNE TWO
THOUSAND THREE. AND THE DAY
AFTER THE ELECTION WAS THE
WORST DAY. GOING BACK- TO ABOUT
THAT THAT THE SAME THAT SAME
TIME- MOREOVER OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS THE SECOND WORST
MONTH. OUR FOR HATE CRIME OR
LAST DECADE ANY CALIFORNIA THE
DAY AFTER ELECTION. WAS WAS THE
WORST DAY OF THAT OF THAT YEAR
INTERESTINGLY THOUGH WE'RE ALSO
SEEING- A DECLINE. IN IN IN
CONVICTIONS IN PROSECUTIONS OF
WITH RESPECT TO- WHEN. WHEN WE
HAVE D. A.'S ACTUALLY WORK ON
SOME AND PROSECUTORS FOR
INSTANCE OF VOICE OF AMERICA
FOUND A 30% DECLINE IN FEDERAL
HATE CRIME PROSECUTIONS. AND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE WE'RE
SEEING ON UNFORTUNATELY- A
DIFFERENCE WITH REGARD TO
CONVICTIONS. SHE GOOD NEWS
BUREAU JUSTICE FOR THE FIRST
TIME SAID THAT THE MAJORITY A
BARE MAJORITY OF HATE CRIME
VICTIMS UP ARE REPORTING SO
WHAT CAN WE DO AND WHAT WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE EXCELLENT. THE
PIECES OF. ADVICE GIVEN IN THE
ORDER WELL THE REALLY TO
TRAINING DATA COLLECTION
COORDINATION POLICY AN OUTRAGE
THE GOOD NEWS IS CALIFORNIA WAS
AMONG THE FIRST DATE- UNDER A-
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL VAN TO
CAMP BACK IN THE EIGHTIES. A TO
PUT TOGETHER TASK FORCES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO WE HAVE THE
CHASSIS WE DON'T HAVE A NEW
TARGET YES THE TUNE UP- AND-
AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE FOUND FOR INSTANCE. WAS A
FAILURE TO IDENTIFY HATE CRIMES
MIS IDENTIFICATIONS UNDER
REPORTING- AND MISS REPORTING
UP AND RATHER THAN GETTING INTO
ALTHOUGH SHE IS I THINK WE HAVE
A VERY SPECIAL PERSON. FOR
THAT- BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
WE ARE CENTER. AGREES WITH THE
SUGGESTIONS OF FOUND AND IN
THEIR AUDIT AND ALSO- WE ABIDE
BY WHAT THE STATUTORY. AND
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS ARE.
THE WORK. WE DO THINK THERE
THERE IS THERE IS A SUMMER FOR
OF ALL WITH REGARD TO
COLLECTION IT REALLY ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE TREND NOW
ESPECIALLY WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE NEW NOT A
BRIS FEDERAL SYSTEM IS TO
REALLY STEP IT UP WITH REGARD
TO THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
THAT IS TRACKED BUT ALSO THE
ADVOCACY IN THE TIMING OF WHEN
THIS INFORMATION COMES OUT AND
THAT WAS PART OF WHAT YOU WANT
TO SUGGEST I'M GONNA DIVERT A
LITTLE BIT. THERE'S SUGGEST
JUST TO A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
AND NYPD COMPSTAT IS NOW GOING
TO HAVE A MONTHLY HATE CRIME A
REVIEW FRIEND WHAT THE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GOING NATIONALLY IN
MANY CITIES OR STARTING TO DO
THIS KIND OF THING I THINK WE
HAVE TO LOOK PORTS SO WHEN WE
ARE ACTUALLY HAVING ACT CHANGES
SINCE CAN LOOK AT. ALL RIGHT
MONTH OR SO THE OPENING POST
YOU ARE AT THE END OF THE YEAR-
MORE OVER A TRAINING- POST HAS
A GREAT MEANING A LOT OF TIME.
WITH ME TO A OUT IN. COULD BE A
BILL PROBLEM BUT YOU'RE
OPPORTUNITIES WE RESPECT TO
ONSITE AND THE INTO AND ONE OF
I'D LIKE SEE. OR OLD GOSH WAS
ABOUT THIRTY AGO OLD THE
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING CENTER TOGETHER OF
PICK TRAINING. ON NATIONAL AND
WHAT WE HAVE IS A STRIKE TEAM
WHICH CONSISTS OF MYSELF AND
OTHER SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
AND PRACTITIONERS PRINCES LIKE
DETECTIVES PEOPLE FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. WE
HAVE A HEAT IN RAPID RESPONSE
TEAM BUT WE GOTTA PUT GASOLINE
IN IT. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK WE SHOULD DO IS
CONSIDER HAVING SOME KIND OF
ROUTINE SIZED AND CONTINUING
TYPES OF. ADVISORY GROUPS WERE
COMMITTEES OUR SYSTEM OF
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT AND
COMMUNITY PEOPLE. MIGHT
OVERLAP- DID DID MEET FOLKS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
LEGISLATURE- AS WELL AS THE
AG'S OFFICE A LEAVE IT TO
OTHERS. AS TO HOW TO HOW TO HOW
TO. DO THAT. ALL SURE HOW OLD I
I'M LIKE TO A ASK UP WE SEND
SEVEN SEVEN A GROUPS INCLUDING
A SENT A LETTER TO THE GO
OFFICE I'M IN IF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD JUST ASSIST
US IN USING YOUR INFLUENCE TO
GET SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS- ON
ON ON THE TABLE- THERE AS WELL-
BUT BOTTOM LINE IS WE KNOW WHAT
WORKS- OUT REACH COORDINATION
WITH WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
CONTINUED INCLUDES NICE
TRAINING ALL I'D BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
BECAUSE THE THERE IS A LIMITED
TIME AND ALSO I'M FLYING OUT OF
BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE THE HONOR
OUR CENTER OF GETTING THE ****
FAMILY AWARD FROM THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM- AND THE CHANCE OR SAID
I GOT TO BE THERE THIS
AFTERNOON SO I LISTEN TO MIKE
MY BOSSES WILL THE BOTTOM LINE
IS HE CRIMES OF APPLY TO HOLD A
BIT. BUT THEY STILL. ARM UP.
MOST OF THE INCREASE OF THE WE
SEE. AND THEY'RE GETTING VICE
MORE OVER WE'RE TERROR TYPE
GROUPS LIKE THE- WHICH ACTUALLY
TO. ME IN ONE OF THE RECRUITING
VIDEOS AND OTHERS ON IN
BROTHERHOOD HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN GETTING MORE VIOLENT
WITHIN THE PRISON SYSTEM SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE SEEING
OTHER STATES DO. IS HAVE TASK
FORCES SOME WHICH IS JUST
DEVOTED TO DOMESTIC TERRORISM
IN NEW YORK NEW JERSEY THEY'RE
CONSIDERING NEW LEGISLATION.
THAT WHEN FIVE OR MORE PEOPLE
ARE TARGETED THAT THAT BECOMES
AN ACT OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM
THERE'S THEIR THEIR ISSUES WITH
THAT DIFFERENT STATES ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT STREAMLINING THEIR
DATA COLLECTION METHODS. AND
CALIFORNIA WHICH ONCE WAS
REALLY AT THE LEAD FOR HAVING
THE HIGHEST NUMBER PER CAPITA
HATE CRIMES BECAUSE WE
COLLECTED THE DATA WELL. HAS
ACTUALLY SLIPPED BEHIND PLACES
LIKE MICHIGAN AND NEW JERSEY.
SO WE CAN'T REST ON OUR
LAURELS- I THINK WE'RE GOING
INTO A VERY TENUOUS TIME. WITH
RESPECT TO HATE CRIME BUT ALSO
POLITICAL VIOLENCE IN THIS
ELECTION YEAR OUR RESEARCH
SHOWED. THAT FROM THIRD QUARTER
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO THIRD QUARTER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AROUND THIS
KIND OF CASH PHONES ALEXIAN
TIME. VIOLENCE WILL DO PATIENTS
IN THIS DEL. TO LEFT THE- A
FULL YEAR THINGS ARE GETTING
MORE VIOLENT HE'S ALSO A DINNER.
TERRORISM TRY. OVER LEASE OR
DATE AND- SHE- IT ARM. LASTLY I
THINK WE NEED TO EXPAND OUR
HICK COVERED TO. IMMIGRANTS DAD
AND THE HOME WE SHOULD SO
ASSEMBLY PERSON GIBSON'S A
REFORM TO ADD HOMELESS TO BONE
WILL GET THEM BUT WE'RE
LITERALLY SEEING THESE PEOPLE
BEING MURDERED- AND AGAIN
LASTLY SOME KIND OF CONTINUING
OPERATIONS- WITH THE AG'S
OFFICE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THE LEGISLATURE WERE OUTSIDE
STAKEHOLDERS AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS GET TO MEET WITH. OUR
OUR VAUNTED OF PUBLIC OFFICIALS
SO THAT WE CAN ADVISE HIM ON A
MORE REGULAR BASIS PERHAPS
QUARTERLY OR BI ANNUALLY- ONCE
AGAIN LET ME JUST. THE CLOTHES
WE THOUGH WHAT KENNEDY SAID THE
NIGHT OF MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS
ASSASSINATED LET'S TRY AND MAKE.
GENTLE THE LIFE OF THIS WORLD
AND- THANK YOU ARE ARE ARE
PUBLIC OFFICIALS FOR PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT.
ISSUE AND I- REMAIN AVAILABLE
REPORT FOR SOME OF THE FINDINGS
IN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
PROFESSOR LEVINE AND MYSELF
JUST PASS OUT OF THE LETTERS
RISING WOULD PROBABLY HAVE SOME
ACTUAL ONES WE CAN PUT IT ALL.
ON THE TABLE- SITE AND ALSO
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU FOR
RECEIVING THE WAYNE FAMIL.
EXCELLENCE AWARD FOR
OUTSTANDING SCHOLARSHIP FOR THE
WHOLE CSU ASSESSMENT. A LATER
DATE SO OUR HOPE YOU CAN CATCH
A PLAN BACK TO- AS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN AN AND DOCTOR
STANLEY WING AND IS A LONG TERM
FRAME FRIEND OFF MY SO IF YOU
SEE HIM. DOWN THERE PLEASE SAY
HI TO- DOCTOR STANLEY. ARGUE
WONDERFUL BENEFACTOR AND THIS
AWARD REALLY GOES TO OUR TEAM
RAY AND BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER ALSO LIKE TO
WILL COME ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS A
REAM. YOU CAN BE JOIN US AND
SENATE. GONZALEZ MEAN COMMENTS
YOU ON THE- MAIL OKAY SO OR
AUDITOR. ELAINE HOWELL PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CHAIR
SALAS MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE RECORD MY NAME'S ELAINE
HOW ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR WITH ME AS ERIN FILNER
MISTER FOUND THERE WAS THE-
PROJECT SUPERVISOR ON THIS
PARTICULAR PRODUCT THE WAY
WE'RE GOING TO HANDLE THIS
PRESENTATION IS YOU DO HAVE A
HANDOUT THAT MR FELDER WILL
STEP YOU THROUGH WHAT I'M GOING
TO DO PRIOR TO THAT IS JUST TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF A
REFRESHER ON THE ISSUES THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT REPORT
THEY AND WILL ALIGN. WITH THEM
THE COMMENT AT TOP MR LEVINE
YES PROVIDED SO AS YOU MAY
RECALL WE ISSUE- THE AUDIT
REPORT AND MAY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO WE AS AFTER WE
ISSUE A REPORT WE RECEIVED
RESPONSES FROM THE ENTITIES
THAT WE'VE AUDITED SIXTY A SIX
MONTH AND ONE YEAR SO THE
PRESENTATION AT MISTER FOUND
THERE WILL BE PROVIDE OKAY WILL
BE AS OF MAY THE RESPONSE WE
READ KEY FOR EACH OF THE ENTITY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO. PRESENT
WILL WILL BE TO TALK ABOUT
THREE TO. CAT VERY SOME TO THE
PRE. SPEAKER OUT REACH
REPORTING AND TRAINING- AND THE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ELEMENTS
OF OUTREACH. SO TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF SCOPE QUICKLY- WE
WERE ASKED TO GO OUT TO A
SAMPLE OF LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
SO WE VISITED LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT. ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF STANISLAUS
COUNTY SHERIFF AND SAN
FRANCISCO STATE. POLICE
DEPARTMENT WE ALSO SURVEYED
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA WE SURVEYED OVER TO
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES RECEIVE
THERE ARE VERY HIGH RESPONSE
RATE ABOUT 70% SO WE HAVE
RESPONSES FROM. A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SO THAT HELPS GIVE. A
STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE IN
ADDITION TO THE- THE WORK THAT
WE DID OUT AT THE FOR ENTITIES
THAT WE VISITED SO WITH RESPECT
TO AN OUT REACH OUR CONCLUSION
WAS THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IS NOT DOING ENOUGH AS FAR AS
CONDUCTING OUT REACH AND THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE COULD
CERTAINLY ASSIST WITH SOME OF
THAT. SO WITH RESPECT TO THE
LOCALS TWO OF THE FOUR ENTITIES
THAT WE VISITED WERE NOT
CONDUCTING ANY OUT REACH AT ALL
IN THE COMMUNITY. AND THEN THE
SURVEY RESPONSE INDICATED THAT
ABOUT 30% OF THE ENTITIES THAT
WE SURVEYED THAT RESPONDED TO
OUR SURVEY SAID. NOW WE WILL
CONDUCT A REACH YOU CAN. USE.
AND THE A CRITICAL PORTENT ON
CERTAINLY BECAUSE- RESEARCH IS
TO. THAT HE CRIMES ARE REAP.
WHY IS THAT. FEAR OF FEAR OF
DEPORTATION LACK OF TRUST IN
THE COMMUNITY NOT REALLY A LACK
OF TRUST IN LAW ENFORCEMENT SO
THERE NEEDS TO BE A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND-
VARIOUS GROUPS IN THE
COMMUNITY. TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO REPORT HATE CRIMES SO THAT
THEY CAN BE ADDRESSED. AND
HOPEFULLY- YOU KNOW THE NUMBERS
ARE REDUCED. DOJ WE BELIEVE IS
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO ASSIST
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRST OF
ALL BECAUSE THEY ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO COLLECT
THE DATA. THEY COULD ANALYZE
THAT DATA AND THEN PROVIDE SOME
ANALYSES TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS FAR AS- DO WE
NEED TO DO TARGETED OUTREACH
AND VERY. AT AREAS OF THE CITY
UP WITH RESPECT TO VARIOUS
GROUPS THAT ARE IN- THEY ARE
VICTIMS OF THESE HATE CRIMES.
IN ADDITION WE IDENTIFY THE
ROUTE. THAT CREATED BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND WHEN
WE DO DURING THE TO THE AUDIT
THERE REALLY. A OF
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THAT
PARTICULAR TEAM- COULD DO AND
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO FOR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES DOJ CERTAINLY WAS
AWARE OF THEIR RESPONSE TEAM
BUT THEY WEREN'T. ADVERTISING
IT THEY WEREN'T ENCOURAGING
LOCALS TO REACH OUT FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO WE
THINK- INCREASING AND IMPROVING
OUT REACH- WILL CERTAINLY HELP.
THESE DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES OUR
SURVEY RESPONDENTS INDICATED I
THINK WAS 83% OF OUR SURVEY
RESPONDENTS SAID THEY HAD NEVER
RECEIVED ANY TYPE OF GUIDANCE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ABOUT HOW TO CONDUCT THE OUT
REACH. HOW IMPORTANT OUT
REACHES- THE BENEFIT THE
BENEFITS OF OUT REACH IT CETERA
SO WE HAD A VARIETY OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ALL OF THE
ENTITIES WITH RESPECT TO
OUTREACH. NOW REPORTING.
CERTAINLY ARE WE FOUND THAT
HATE CRIMES WERE UNDER REPORTED
WE DID SOME ANALYSES OF-
INFORMATION THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM THE ENTITIES THAT WE
SURVEYED WE ASK THEM TO REPORT
THEIR- A HATE CRIME DATA AND WE
COMPARED IT TO THE DATA THAT
WAS REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. AND THERE WERE
DIFFERENT. INFORMATION WE WERE
FROM THE- WAS HIGHER NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER BUT HIGHER
SO THERE WAS A DISCONNECT
THERE. WE ALSO CAN AUDITS OF
CAMPUS CRIME. REPORTING THAT
UNDER THE CLEAR ACT THAT'S A
STATURE MEANT THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THAT EVERY THREE YEARS
SO WE LOOKED AT THE CLEARY.
INFORMATION AND WE AGAIN FOR.
PERMISSION AND A CLEAR IT
REPORTS. OF THAT UNIVERSITIES
HAVE TO SUBMIT THAT WERE NOT
SOME OF THOSE CRIME SHOULD HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE HATE CRIME
DATA THAT WAS REPORTED TO THE
STATE TO DO JAKE. AND WE FOUND
DIFFERENCES THERE SO THERE'S
REALLY. AT THE TIME WE
CONDUCTED THERE ARE THERE WERE
REALLY SOME CONCERNS WITH RISK
TO. FULL AND ACCURATE REPORT
FROM THE LOCALS UP TO THE FRONT
OF JUST. SO. WE FELT DOJ A- IS
UNIQUE POSITIONED THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE OVER. TO LAW FOR. FIRST
QUESTION WHERE DOJ IS WHO ALL
ARE THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES THAT YOU'RE RECEIVING
DATA FROM. AND THEY AT THAT
TIME DID NOT HAVE A COMPLETE
LIST OF ALL THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
SHOULD BE REPORTING THIS DATA.
TO DOJ SO THAT WAS THAT WAS
CONCERNED NUMBER ONE. CONCERN
NUMBER TWO AGAIN WHAT DO JANE
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO THE
LOCALS AS TO WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS WERE. WITH RESPECT
TO WHAT THEY SHOULD REPORT WHEN
THEY SHOULD REPORT IT- SO THE
THIS SURVEY AGAIN INDICATED
THAT MANY MANY OF. A HIGH
PERCENT OVER 80% OF THE
ENTITIES THAT WE SURVEYED SAID
AGAIN WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY
TYPE OF GUIDANCE FROM THE OKAY.
ABOUT THE TYPES OF. READ THAT
WE NEED TO SUBMIT THE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO
SUBMIT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND THE FINAL THING
WITH RESPECT TO REPORTING IS
DOJ WASN'T LOOKING AT THOSE
REPORTS AND DOING AN ANALYSIS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS BEING
REPORTED WAS ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE. SO THAT IF THEY DID
AN ANALYSIS AGAIN TYING BACKED
OUT REACH THEY WOULD HAVE THE
CORRECT INFORMATION TO DO AN
APPROPRIATE ANALYSIS- AND THEN
THE LAST AREA IS TRAINING
TRAINING IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE WHAT WE
FOUND AS AS PROFESSOR LEVINE
INDICATED THERE WERE AND MANY
INSTANCES WHERE A CRIME WAS
MISIDENTIFIED. IT WAS
IDENTIFIED AS A HATE INCIDENT
AND IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CATEGORIZED AS A HATE CRIME. SO
THAT LEADS TO UNDER REPORTING-
AND WE FOUND THAT CONSISTENTLY.
AMONG THE LOCAL ENTITIES THAT
WE VISITED WHERE THEY WERE
MISCLASSIFIED CERTAIN CRIMES.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLASSIFIED AS
A CRIME. AND IN MANY CASES WAS
CLASS AND AS A INCIDENT.
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY
THERE. I HATE CRIMES ALSO NOT
USING ALL OF THE TOOLS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THERE'S SOMETHING
CALLED THE SUPPLEMENTAL- HATE
CRIME REPORT. THAT REALLY CAN
ASSIST LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND IDENTIFYING A HATE CRIME SO
THAT IT CAN BE REPORTED. AND
SOME OF THE ENTITIES WE VISITED
MANY OF THE ENTITIES WE
SURVEYED WERE NOT USING THIS
SUPPLEMENTAL HATE CRIME REPORT.
SO AGAIN MORE GUIDANCE MORE
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL SO THAT
THEY DO CORRECTLY- FULLY AND
ACCURATELY REPORT HATE CRIMES
TO. DOJ SO DOJ CAN PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO LOCALS. THE FINAL
AREA WITH RESPECT TO TRAINING
IS AGAIN UP POST THE COMMISSION
ON PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING WHAT WE FOUND IS IN
THE POLICE ACADEMY THEY DO
PROVIDE SOME TRAINING WITH
RESPECT TO HATE CRIMES. BUT
WHAT WE FOUND IS THERE IS NO
REFRESHER TRAINING IT'S THE ONE
TIME YOU'RE IN THE ACADEMY
RECEIPT RECEIVE THAT TYPE OF
TRAINING. VERY FEW OF THE
ENTITIES THAT WE VISITED WERE
PROVIDING ANY REFRESHER
TRAINING- MOST OF THE ENTITIES
THAT WE- SURVEYED SAID THEY'RE
NOT PROVIDING REACHED REFRESHER
TRAINING EITHER. WHAT WE DID
FIND THIS POST HAD SOME GOOD
TRAINING- THEY HAD TRAINING
AVAILABLE THAT WAS FREE THEY
HAD MATERIALS THAT WERE FREE
THAT COULD BE PROVIDED TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ALLOW LOW
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO. I
HAVE THEIR OFFICERS RECEIVE
REFRESHER TRAINING- SO WE FELT
THAT WE NEEDED TO HAPPEN WE
MADE SOME RECOMMENDED TO RAISE.
TO THE OTHER ISSUE TO POSTED
WHETHER OR NOT WERE A FOR.
ANALYZE HOW WELL AS HOW IS THIS
TRAINING KING THE TRAY THAT IS
PROVIDE IT IT IS IT. WORKING
FOR. IT GIVES THEM AN
INFORMATION. THANK DO OUR BEST
JOB. WHEN THEY OUT RESPONDING
TO AN SAID. AND DETERMINING
IT'S A CRIME NEEDS TO BE. OR
WHETHER IT'S SHOULD BE CLASS AS
A HATE INCIDENT SO WE HAD
RECOMMENDATIONS TO POST AS WELL.
SO THAT'S A VERY QUICK OVERVIEW
OF THE THREE AREAS- THAT WERE
LAID OUT IN THE AUDIT REPORT
WHAT MR OUND THERE IS GOING TO
DO IS HE'S GOING TO STEP YOU
THROUGH THIS SUMMARY DOCUMENT
WHICH WILL TAKE YOU THROUGH.
ALL OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MADE TO THE TO THE ENTITIES AND
WHAT THE CURRENT STATUS IS OF.
EACH ENTITIES IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BUT THE FIRST PAGE WE
HAVE A SUMMARY ON THE STATUS OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THERE'S
TWENTY ONE IN TOTAL AND THEN ON
PAGE TWO ALTHOUGH HAD WALK YOU
THROUGH THE STATUS THIS REX
INDIVIDUALLY. THIS PAGE DETAILS
THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO DOJ
CONCERNING OUTREACH EFFORTS TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
SPECIFICALLY WANTED DOJ TO
CREATE AND DISSEMINATE OUTREACH
MATERIALS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE TO USE WHEN THEY
GO OUT SPECIFICALLY TO- FOCUS
ON AVERAGE TO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THOSE FROM AND-
EXPERIENCE A HATE CRIME AND
THOSE- LEAST LEAST LIKELY TO
REPORTED WE DID FIND. THAT THE
KIND OF AT THE ONE YEAR MARK
THEY DOJ HAS UPDATED ITS HATE
CRIME PAMPHLET AND THIS
WEBSITE. AND ALSO HOSTED A HATE
CRIME OF EVENTS BOB HOWEVER IT
IS YET TO DISTRIBUTE OR CREATE
ANY NEW MATERIALS RELATED TO
OUTREACH EFFORTS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES COULD USE.
SO ALTHOUGH IT IS PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED THEY HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO THERE FOR THIS FIRST
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS. THE THIRD
RECOMMENDATION THE PAGE DETAILS
THE HE CRIME RAPID RESPONSE
TEAM. NOW WITH. IDEAS EXPERTS
DOJ THAT GO TO THIS LONG FORCED
WHENEVER THEY- A ARRAY OF A CAR
ARE ONE X. EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH
PRO. CASE HOWEVER ONLY HALF OF
LONG FOR SO AGENCIES. WE
SURVEYED EVEN KNEW OF ITS
EXISTENCE ADDED NEVER EVEN BEEN
DEPLOYED. SO WE RECOMMENDED
THAT AND DOJ HAS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED- KIND OF SENDING
OUT INFORMATIONAL NOTICES
UPDATING ITS WEBSITE AND MAKING
SURE THAT ALL THE ENTITIES AND
STATE NEW- THAT THEY COULD RELY
ON DOJ IF THIS WERE TO HAPPEN.
SAID SIT OUT REACH ON THAT PAGE
THREE. WE DISCUSS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO DOJ RELATED
TO IMPROVING HATE CRIME
REPORTING. NOW THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION THERE IS TO
DEVELOP A LIST OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE ALL THE
REPORTS THEY NEED SO WHEN WE
FIRST WENT OUT TO DOJ NOT ONLY
DID THEY HAVE AN INCOMPLETE
LIST OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES THAT WERE REQUIRED TO
REPORT TO THE MONTHLY BUT 40%
OF THE INFORMATION FOR
CONTACTING THOSE IN AGENCIES
WAS INCORRECT OR INCOMPLETE. SO
EVEN IF THEY WANTED TO SEND A
NOTE. WE COULDN'T IN ADDITION
WE ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT THEY
SEND OF GUIDANCE ON HOW TO
REPORT ACCURATELY TO THE AGENT.
TO THE TO ALL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES. AND THEN
CONDUCT PERIODIC REVIEWS SO
ONCE THE NEW OKAY WE'RE GETTING
THE REPORTS FROM EVERYONE EACH
EACH MONTH. ARE THEY DOING A
DISTRIBUTOR WHICH FOR THAT
THAT'S ACCURATE BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT ABOUT 20% OF THE HE CRIME
REPORTS. SENT TO DOJ WERE AN
ACTOR IN SOME RESPECT. SO DOJ
HAS DEVELOPED SOME NEW
PROCEDURES- TO LOCATE AND ADD
NEW LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
ITS LIST. OF REQUIRED
REPORTERS. AND IT HAS DRAFTED
SOME DOCUMENTATION AND AIDS FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES TO USE
TO ENSURE THAT THE REPORTING
ACCURATELY. HOWEVER IT HASN'T
FINALIZED ANY OF THAT GUIDANCE-
OR POSTED. OR DISSEMINATED. IT
ALSO HAS DEVELOPED ANY SYSTEM
TO ENSURE THAT THE REPORT THAT
IT IS RECEIVING ARE- ARE
ACCURATE. SO THERE'S- KIND OF
SOME MOVEMENT SOME PROGRESS BUT
AGAIN IT'S KIND OF. YET TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDED ANY THE ELEMENTS
THAT RECOMMENDATION. IN A TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS PAGE
ARE AIMED AT INCREASING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF REPORTING THE
DOJ. SO THAT WOULD INCLUDE
ADDING IS ZIP CODE WHEN WE
FOUND THAT A LOT OF THESE
JURISDICTIONS THAT THESE- LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ITS RESPONSE
BEFORE VERY LARGE SB NO ALLEY
PD- BAKERSFIELD ASH- KERN
COUNTY SHERIFF THINGS LIKE
THAT. AND THAT IT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT EVEN IF DOJ WERE TO
ANALYZE WHERE HE COMES A
RECURRING TO ACTUALLY GET
ANYTHING SUBSTANTIVE TO- TO THE
LOCALS. ESPECIALLY THE CASE
WHERE SAY THERE WAS A RASH OF
SIMILARLY TYPE TAKE CRIMES
OCCURRING IN A REGION THAT WAS
YOU KNOW. GOING TO MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS. SO WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE- AND DOJ
IS PENDING IMPLEMENTATION ON
THEIR CYBER SYSTEMS OF CYBER IS
THE- HAVE THE IT'S GOING TO GET
DOJ WORKING WITH DIVERSE THE
NATIONAL SYSTEM. CYBER SHOULD
HAVE THE FUNCTIONALITY TO
INCLUDE AS ZIP CODE AND ADDRESS
INFORMATION FOR EACH HATE CRIME
REPORT. AND THEN CYBER SHOULD
ALSO HAVE THE FUNCTIONALITY TO
ALLOW DOJ TO SEARCH FOR
PARTICULAR HATE CRIMES AND THEN
SEND OUT ALERTS TO LOCALS WHEN
THEY FIND OUT THAT- THAT THERE
MIGHT BE CRIMES OCCURRING
ACOSTA SPECIFIC REGION THAT
IMPLEMENTATION CYBER IS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SO THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE PENDING
THAT IMPLEMENTATION NEXT YEAR.
ON PAGE FOUR- WE'VE
RECOMMENDATION TO DOJ AND POST
CONCERNING HATE CRIME TRAINING.
SPECIFICALLY WE RECOMMENDED
THAT DOJ PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND PRODUCE TRAINING
MATERIALS FOR THEM- NOW DOJ HAS
WORKED WITH POST TO UPDATE ITS
MODEL HE CRIME POLICY POSTS
MULLIN PRINT POLICIES KIND OF
THE TEMPLATE OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIESCOULD USE
WHEN BUILDING THEIR OWN OF
CREATING THEIR OWN POLICY-
HOWEVER DOJ HASN'T. DEVELOPED
OR DISSEMINATED ANY TRAINING
MATERIALS OF ITS OWN SO
ALTHOUGH IT'S ON SOME WORK IT'S
STILL ONLY PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED THE- TO RECORD IS
THE BOTTOM OF THAT PAGE ON FOR
ARE DIRECTED TO POST. AND TO
PUSH CREDIT IT HAS FULLY IN
BOTH RECOMMEND. AND THOSE ARE
TWO TO SAN TAKE CRY TRAINING AS
LONG FOR ENTITY. AND ALSO
EVALUATE THAT PERIODICALLY
POSTS. AS SUBS OVER ISSUED.
SENATOR CD TO ALSO HUNDRED PLUS
LAW FORCED AGENCIES THAT THAT
IT. IT ALSO. HOSTED THE HATE
CRIME TRAINING ITS WEB. FOR
ANYONE TO TAKE IN. ANYONE WHO
TAKES THE TRAINING OR AS AN
INSTRUCTOR FOR THE TRAINING CAN
GIVE FEEDBACK TO POST VIçT
PORTAL. SO IT'S IMPLEMENT A
BOTH OF THOSE. FINALLY A FIVE
PAGE FIVE OF THESE INCLUDES
REGULAR TO THE FORD ENFORCEMENT
AGE WITH. FOR REVIEW NOW WE
SHOULD THIS TO WRITTEN THAT.
AND FRANCIS STATE POLICE TO.
NAMELY THAT THEY TO BOTH UPDATE
HATE CRIMES. AND PROVIDE
GUIDANCE IN OVERSIGHT ON
REPORTING BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT
THEY WERE NOT IDENTIFYING HATE
CRIMES APPROPRIATELY AND THEY
WERE UNDER REPORTING HATE
CRIMES THAT THEY EVEN DID
IDENTIFY CORRECTLY. SO IN
RESPONSE- SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY POLICE DEPARTMENT
HAS FULLY IMPLEMENTED BOTH OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS. THE HATE
CRIME POLICY UPDATED HAS
BROUGHT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW. AND IS NOW ACTIVELY-
LOOKS AT THE REPORT SUBMITTED
EACH MONTH TO DOJ TO INSURE
THEIR ACCURATE SO DEVOID OF
BOTH RECOMMENDATIONS THERE LAPD
HAS DRAFTED A NEW HATE CRIME
POLICY APPARENTLY IT'S A LARGE
EXPANSION ON THE OLD ONE. AND
THEY'VE INDICATED TO US THAT IT
WILL IMPLEMENT BOTH
RECOMMENDATIONS WHEN IT IS
FINALIZED. AND I BELIEVE YOU
TALKED WITH A- LET'S TAKE TO
FOR FROM LAPD CAN YOU AN UPDATE.
THE FINAL TO RECOMMEND ON THE
PAGE CAN OR COUNTY STANNIS.
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS.
NOW THESE TWO COUNTIES DIDN'T
HAVE SUPPLEMENTAL HE CRIME
REPORTS POST RECOMMENDED THAT
HAVING A SOPHOMORE HE CRIME
REPORT WAS CRITICAL BECAUSE ONE
OFFICERS WARRANT DON'T GET A
LOT OF EXPERIENCING HATE CRIMES
DON'T KNOW WHAT QUESTIONS TO
ASK. AND PROSECUTORS REALLY
NEED THAT ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE
IN ORDER TO GET CONVICTIONS.
AND ORANGE COUNTY TO ITS CREDIT
DID AND- CREATE AND REQUIRE
OFFICERS TO USE A SUPPLE HE
CRIME REPORT WITHIN SIXTY DAYS
THE REPORTS REPORTS ISSUANCE.
STANISLAUS COUNTY INDICATED
THAT ITS CURRENT REPORTS WERE
ADEQUATE AND IT WOULD NOT
CREATE A NEW ONE AND HAS NOT
RESPONDED TO ANY SUBSCRIBER
RESPONDENTS FROM US AFTER THE
SIXTY DAY ISSUANCE. SO THEY
HAVE A THERE'S BEEN NO MOVEMENT
NO ACTION TAKEN ON THAT
RECOMMENDATION. FINALLY ON PAGE
SIX- THERE'S LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ALL MERE THOSE
DIRECTED TO DOJ AND POST. THAT
OF WHICH HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
BUT THERE HAS BEEN LEGISLATION
INTRODUCED THAT WOULD HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THESE WRECKS. AND
OUR HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LOG IN EVERY
YOUR MEETING YOUR ALL THAT READ
REPORT ONE ONE JOB AS YOU COULD
GO TO YOUR STAFF AS WE- AS
WOULD WE WOULD ALSO JOINED BY
SEN. WAR AND ALSO ARE OF
APPROVED CHAIR OF MEMBER
GONZALEZ WHERE DO WAS A AB
THROUGH OLD AND IF WE HAVE TWO
FOUR WITH BUT ANYWAY. EIGHT
NOTED THE OPPORTUNITY HERE AND
SAUL WOULD BE A REALLY OF UP
FOR AND THE IS YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. A ANYBODY. FOR A
DOCTOR CHOI. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BUT I WANNA AS I IT IS MY- I AM
BEGINNING TO. WONDER HOW YOU DO.
THE CRIME BECAUSE OR OR LEAVE A
I THOUGHT THAT SOME MEMBER HE
CRIME MEANS SOME MORE OF THE IN
A GENDER. A RE THE RE TO OR
REYES SO READ. TELL WHAT I.
RIDLEY THE- JEWISH BE WERE.
COMPLAIN AND AS YOU T. PAY WILL
COME. AND MINORITY PEOPLE
COMPLAIN AND OF THE- AREAS A
BUTTON. COME TO. THINK ABOUT IT
THAT L. OR THE CRIME ME YOU CAN.
IF I HATE CRIME. IN YOU ALSO
MENTION THAT THE ONE OF THE TO
DID NOT A DEAF IN OF A CRIME IS
SO HOW WOULD YOU DEFINE. IN US
ON SOME MENTIONED EVEN PUBLIC
CRIME TO IT IT IT HAD TO THIS
RIGHT NOW IS TO DO A BRICK TO.
IN A DEMOCRATS TO AND WAS GOING
ON RIGHT NOW SO IN IT BECOMES
SO BLOATED WITH THIS AND THIS
IN THE DAY AND AGE YOU WHAT DO
YOU DEFINE NASSAU HATE CRIME
ANYTHING THAT THE YOU DO. THE
IF I SOMETHING SOMETHING STUNT
TO THE NEIGHBOR- IS IT BECAUSE
OF A FEMALE LIVING IN THERE MAY
THE INDIA SINGLE LIVING IN
THEIR OLD WHAT THE IN A HOW
WOULD YOU DEFINE IT DAY BECOMES
BLOW TO ME. I THINK THERE SO
THERE'S SUPPORT HATE CRIME IN A
HATE WHERE HE CRIME IS A CRIME
ACT. IT WHOLE OR IN BECAUSE OF
A PERCEIVED CHARACTER ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED CHARACTERISTICS BASED
ON DISABILITY GENDER
NATIONALITY RACE ETHNICITY
RELIGION. SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
WHERE AS A HEAT INCIDENT. SO
THAT THAT'S WHERE THERE'S A
HEAT INCIDENT IS WHERE THERE
THERE'S CRIME CT TO SEE SEATED
THE ACT TO PAY SO COULD BE HATE
SPEECH. BUT THERE IS NO WAS VAN.
SO WITH THAT. SO IT'S VERY
CLEAR THE LOWER KINDA HATE
CRIME AND THAT. WHAT OTHER. LOS
AGENCY MIGHT TRY WHICH ARE HE
INSTANCE. YEAH BUT JUST
INTERJECT ARM. IN CALIFORNIA IT
IT HAS TO BE ONE OF THE MOTIVE.
IN FOR TODAY THE A LEADS I HOPE
I DIDN'T JUMP THE GUN IS THE
BEING AND WHY OTHER WOULD AND
THEY- OB TO CLOSE A FELT
LOOPHOLE WHICH WE- WANT THE
CIRCUIT SAID THAT. MUST BE A
FOUR UP TO PUT IT IF I COULD
JUST. SO SOMETHING THAT WITH
THE TO A THE- UP ONE THINGS
THAT WE DID IN COOPERATE BUZZ
AS WE LOOK AT CITY IN THE
UNITED. AND LOOK AT AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT REPORT AND WE ACTUALLY
FOUND A BUNCH. WE'RE NOT
CLASSIFY HE CRY YOU LOW
VERBIAGE CONTEXTUAL INFORMATION
WAS CLEARLY THERE AND WE WERE
SEEING LARGE CITIES LIKE NEWARK
REPORTING LIKE ZERO OR IT WAS
WE SHOULD BE IT'S SIXTEEN
COUNTY. HERE ONE THING THAT BE
HELPFUL AND THIS IS WHY I I'D
LIKE TO DEFER TO THE AUDITOR'S.
ON THEIR REGULATORY AND
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS BUT
BOTTOM LINE THE FBI SUGGEST THE
TWO HEAR. A REVIEW WHERE IT'S
NOT JUST WHAT IS YOUR BY WAY
FOR YOU SO FOR YOUR YOUR LEDGER.
WITH RESPECT TO SEE FORMS IN PA.
ALL THE TO REVIEW WOULD NOT AT
THE TOP. OF THE CALL. BUT
AFTERWARDS DO SOME LIKE FOR
WHATEVER STANFORD POLICY REVIEW
HE- LIAISON OFFICER COULD BE
THE- TO OR SOME OF LIKE THAT
THE ACTUAL. FOLLOWS UP AND LOOK
AT THE KEY OF THE COME IN MOST
DO HAVE THAT MANY KEY THE
COMING AND PROTECT. CASES IN
SCHOOL VANDALISM AB ASSAULT OR
WE SEE A G. PATTERN IT WOULD BE
A GOOD IDEA TO SOME WAY
MEMORIALIZED SECOND HERE
REVIEW. IN THE STATE HERE UP
NOW WHETHER THAT'S DONE BY
POLICY OR LEGISLATION I'LL
LEAVE THAT TO OTHERS AT A
HIGHER P. GREED THE ME TO
DECIDE. AND ON. GREAT ASSEMBLY.
IS FILLED. YES AND I SURE
ACTUALLY I WAS IN **** BECAUSE-
HE KNOW YOU CALL IT THE DEVICE.
OF HATE. ACROSS ALL THE GROUPS
AND SIX COUNTIES ARE. BUT I WAS
WONDERING HOW MUCH OF THAT WAS
BECAUSE OF DEFINITION- BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE GUIDELINES
OF PROCEDURES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT-
BECAUSE AND WE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE- TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION WHETHER THAT'S DONE
LEGISLATIVELY OR WHETHER THAT'S
DONE- THROUGH ANOTHER MEANS AND
I'M JUST. TRYING TO SEE THE
COMET JUST ON THAT BECAUSE OF
TRYING TO FIND SOME. ACTIONABLE
ITEMS WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH SO
THE MICHIGAN DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DOES HAVE A DOES
INITIATED DESK REVIEW PROCESS
AND ALL OF THE HATE CRIMES TO
COME IN AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
PER CAPITA RATE OF HATE CRIMES
IS ALMOST DOUBLE. WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S IS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT MIGHT THEY'RE
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO THAT
MAYBE BECAUSE THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ASKING FOR ALL OF THE
REPORTS FROM THE LOCALS. AND
CHECKING THEIR WORK AND
CHECKING TO SEE ARE YOU
REPORTING ALL OF THEM SO THAT'S
WHY WE MADE THAT RECOMMENDATION
TO IDEA DATA ALSO. A CALIFORNIA
DOD TO DO THAT AND THE LATEST
DATA NEW JERSEY ONLY ABOUT NINE
MILLION PEOPLE REPORTED ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY HE CROSSED.
IN NINETEEN. OUT OF COURSE THE
MUCH MORE DOWN POPULATED. STATE
AND- THAT ARE LEFT DENSELY. HOW
THE OF A LOWER A- BUT WE'RE
ROUTINE SEEN. OUR MANY
JURISDICTION. NOT ONLY UP LOW
POPULATION COUNTIES THE WAY. OF
TO REPORT BUT LARGE CITIES FROM
SOME LIKE ADD. WHICH IS IN THE
TO TOP TEN. REPORTS LIKE ZERO
TWO AND GIVEN YEAR. SIR WE
SAYING THEN THE D. NUMBERS OF A-
SHOWING ID OR PROP. NOT THE
FULL PICTURE. BECAUSE THEY'RE
JUST NOT BEING REPORTED
CORRECTLY- THESE FORMS ON
EXISTS TO ACTUALLY SHOW HATE
INCIDENCES THAT COULD POSSIBLY
CLASSIFIES HATE CRIMES I MEAN
IN MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
CORRECTLY. YES IT CERTAINLY
WITHIN THE MARGIN OF THE MARGIN
VERY GIVEN CHIP BUT IT IS ALSO
NATIONALLY- THE- TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LAS VEGAS. DIDN'T
SEND IN THEIR ENVELOPE. THAT
WOULD CHANGE THE NATIONAL
PICTURE GIVE AN EXAMPLE SO YEAH
IT'S IT BUT CERTAINLY WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU FROM FROM WHAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEING. ARE WE HAVE
HAD THIS SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND IN
PARTICULAR- THESE THESE VIOLENT
THESE VIOLENT CRIMES AND
HOMICIDES. WHEN HE SAID
EXTREMISTS HOMICIDES EARLIER
WHAT KIND OF INCIDENCES ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. YOU SAID YOU HAD
REPORTED FIVE. WELL WHAT WHAT
WE THE CAN CALIFORNIA. HAS HAS
NOT. A LEAD. AS A HATE AT POINT.
BUT WHEN SOME WRITES ME A
INPUTS ON THE ON ON SO MEDIA WE
HAVE AN OUT. TO PUT AS A PAAS.
OUR FORCES. EVEN IF THAT HASN'T
BEEN OF NUMEROUS SUCH WE WILL
COUNT AS A WHITE SUPREMACIST IT
IN THAT WE HAD POWER WAY FOR
INSTANCE THAT EASILY COULD HAVE
BEEN A DISASTER WHAT I'M SAYING
TO YOU IS WE'RE SEEING THESE
CLUSTERS OF ATTACKS. SOME OF
WHICH COULD BE MASS HOMICIDE
INS INSTANCES AND WE'RE SEEING
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH NO CRIMINAL
RECORDS AND ASSAULT WEAPONS.
OFTENTIMES COMMITTING THEM- AND
THAT'S DISTURBING AND WISHING
THAT NOT ONLY A ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES BUT WE'RE SEEING
IT INTERNATIONALLY AND YOU DID
THE GROUP TO PUT ME IN THEIR
AGE THE- THEIR VIDEO. YOUR
SEVEN ARRESTS LAST WEEK AND
THEY WERE GOING TO GO TO
RICHMOND- AND BY THE WAY JUST
ONE WITH A QUICK THING UP
CERTAIN PLACES DO CAL POLITICS
MOTION DON'T WASHINGTON DC FOR
EXAMPLE- BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS WE'RE
GOING TO SEE AN INCREASE. IN IN
A POSSIBLY INCREASING BOTH
BECAUSE YOUR SEEMS TO BE A
CORRELATION TO CERTAIN
CATALYTIC POLITICAL EVENTS LIKE
ELECTIONS WE HAVE. THIRTY YEARS
WORTH OF DATA LOOKING AT THAT.
AT OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY JOB WE GO TO COOL. CALLED
HER I JUST MOTOR. ASSEMBLY MY
GET. JUDGE THIS. GROUP. APPLE
QUESTIONS THINK PART OF PROBLEM
IS YOU HAVE HATE CRIME THE INTO.
IT'S IS THE A CRIME THAT'S WE
BIG ISSUE STILL IN. YOU GO BACK
TO PATROL TYPE SNOT AND WHAT
HAVE IN YOUR COMPUTER GO INTO A
IT'S A REPORTS THAT. THAT'S
VERY VAGUE IN A BIG THAT'S THE
REASON YOU GET THE INFORMATION
ON THAT. AND NUMBER TWO DEAL
JAY IS TOUGH AND THEY'VE GOT
THEIR- HERE HATE INTEREST. TEAM
THEY HAVE. OVER BECAUSE- BUT
TIME YOU GET BOOKS LIKE. A DEAL
WITH IT. THAT'S LATER SO
THERE'S THAT'S POP. AND HAVING.
VERSUS HAVING LOCALS THAT
REALLY DEAL WITH THAT. AND GET
THE REPUTATION IN ALL THE TIME.
DOING WITH THAT DAY IN AND DAY
OUT. AND IT IS FAR AS TRAINING
GOES SO LAW ENFORCEMENT. THEY
HAVE TWENTY FOUR HOURS EVERY
TWO YEARS OF TRAINING. AND MOST
OF IT IS. THE REFRESHER
TRAINING BUT- THERE'S A NAME
FOR IN SERVICE. PERSONAL SKILLS
PERSONAL SKILLS. SO THAT'S
FIRST AID CPR MANDATED BY THE
STATE. FIRE IN OTHER COURSES
WHATEVER ELSE IS COMING UP AND
NOW USED TO FOR SO. YOU HAVE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS EVERY TWO
YEARS. YOU'RE PULLING YOUR
OFFICERS OFF THE STREET. IS A
STATE REIMBURSING BECAUSE IF
SOMEONE GOD AND AREN'T WORKING-
HOPEFULLY IS COVERED BUT IN
MOST CASES NOT COVERED. SO YOU
CAN'T REIMBURSE THAT ALSO BEING
GODS YOU'RE PAYING OVERTIME.
FOR SOME OF THE BACK FILL
BEHIND THAT SO. YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'VE GOT MORE MINUTES THIS
YEAR FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
THAT'S- THE IN. EVERYTHING'S
PROBLEMATIC WITH THAT AND HOW
DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT. BECAUSE
IT WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH DOWN
MANDATES. AND FOR MOST MANDATES
THERE ARE FUND. IS NOT FUNDED
IF THIS LOW PRIORITY- YOUR
BOTTOM LINE IS PUTTING COPS ON
THE STREET SO. I THINK THE
BIGGEST THING ON THE MY TAKE
AWAY FROM THIS IS. ON THE
INCIDENTS. IT'S TOUGH I SAYS
THIS NOT A CRIME. SO DOOR THAT
YOU'RE DO WITH INTO. OFF SO
DIPPING ON WHO YOU ARE. HOW YOU
PERCEIVE IT OKAY BECAUSE
THREATS HAPPEN ALL THE TIME.
AND I'M NOT TALKING TO SAY
THREATS WERE I'M GONNA KILL YOU.
OKAY IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME. A
LITTLE GOES JOB BEHIND THAT.
YOU CAN THREATEN YOU FIRST NOW
RIGHT YOU CAN THREATEN ALL YOU
WHAT SO. IT'S A TRAINING ISSUE
BUT IT'S HOW DO YOU DO THAT
DEFINITION. AND STILL TAKE THAT
HUMAN PART OUT OF IT SO IT'S
HER SICK THREATS OR ILLEGAL IN
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT I WILL BUT I
TELL YOU THE THIRTY YEAR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. PEOPLE SO THAT ALL
THE TIME KILL YOU TO DO THIS.
AND THEY DON'T GO TO BECAUSE
NOT GONNA GET PROSECUTED FOR
IT. SO TERRORIST THREATS. OR TO
FLY IT IN THE CERTAIN. MALE
SCHEME OF THINGS SO. THAT
THAT'S THE REALITY HERE SO WE
CAN PASS MORE LAWS BUT- USUALLY
DO SO MUCH WITH THAT THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO. LET'S STATES. WHEN THE
FUN MORE TRAINING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ASSEMBLY BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER LET ME OUT OF
A- IF I IF I MIGHT I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE OUR
COLLECTION OF DATA- WHETHER
TAKE CRIMES OR HATE INCIDENTS.
BECAUSE UNDERSTANDING THIS
MILIEU IS- IS THE KEY. TO DOING
WHAT I THINK WE DON'T DO ENOUGH
OF- AND THAT IS. COMMIT
RESOURCES AND AFTER. THE
PREVENT BEEN. A HATE CRIMES AND
AN ANSWER. THAT A CERTAIN.
WE'RE REALLY TO MOVE- MORE TO
THAT DISCUSSION- I'M REMINDED
OF THE TESTIMONY AND- SAMPER A
DINO- WHEN- WE HAD OUR HEARING
BACK IN THE FALL. OF THE
TESTIMONY OF BUDGET GROUP WHO.
A FOR LEADER OF EIGHT NATIONAL
WHITE NATIONALIST. OR
ORGANIZATION WHO LEFT- I HIS
ORGANIZATION AND NOW- DOES OUT
REGION SCHOOLS IN A NUMBER OF-
OF OTHER- VENUES. OF THAT KIND
OF EFFORT I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- WE NEED TO
FIND WAYS TO REACH OUT TO YOUNG
PEOPLE- THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT I THINK- IN THE
ONLINE WORLD. BACK IN MY YOUTH-
HATE SPEECH HPPEN ON THE
PLAYGROUND THAT WAS YOU KNOW
THAT WAS THAT WAS WHERE I HEARD
IT- AS I WAS GROWING UP BUT I'M
SURE MANY OTHERS TODAY IT'S
WITH A SET OF HEADPHONES ON
YOUR PARTICIPATING IN A- A
GAMER CONVERSATION WITH
SOMEBODY WHO MIGHT BE ANOTHER.
PART OF THE COUNTRY ANOTHER
PART OF THE WORLD- BUT YET
THOSE MESSAGES ARE ARE BEING
SPREAD AND RECEIVED AND- THOSE
INCIDENTS IN THOSE CRIMES-
CUMULATIVELY IN MY VIEW ARE THE
THING THAT ARE LEADING TO
GREATER VIOLENCE IN SOCIETY
TODAY. ON THE OTHER THING THAT
I THINK- WE DON'T PAY ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO IS UP PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO THE VICTIMS OF
HATE CRIMES I WAS JUST YOU KNOW
ONE LITTLE- WEALTH FOR THOSE
WHO ARE AFFECTED BY IT IT'S
GIGANTIC BUT A SMALL SLIVER. OF
FOR THE HATE CRIME INCIDENT
WORLD IS- OAK- INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE MULTI RACIAL TRANS GENDER
WHO ARE THIRTY THREE TIMES MORE
LIKELY. TO OCCUR SUICIDE AND.
OTHERS BUT IN MY ALTHOUGH THE
IN NOT BE A SHOWING IT THE- A-
THAT POPULATE BEING THE VICTOR.
OVER AND OVER. OF HATES AND
THEN. AND CRY. IS WHAT'S
LEADING TO THAT HI ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE RATE. THANK YOU VERY
GOOD POINT OF ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. WHO WILL MOVE ON TO
THE LET ME HOPE YOU HAVE A
FINAL CONCLUSION NOW WE ARE
HERE ARE THIS OF AND HELP TO.
ME TO REDUCE THE HATE. BUT THE
THROUGH THE TRAINING THAT YOU
TALK ABOUT. SPEND A LACK OF
TRAINING YOU ATTRACT BLAME.
THIS TRAIN OF THE LAW AND FOR
PEOPLE IS IDENTIFY. WHAT ARE
THE- HATE CRIMES BUT THE CAN A
REDUCE OR MINIMIZE SAYS SUCH A
HATE CRIME THAT'S MY QUESTION.
WHAT CAN YOU DO ABOUT IT IN ALL
AS I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT ON FOURTEEN THIS IS
SO JUST A IN ALL OF. ON ON.
HUMAN TRAIT THEY THE TEND TO.
ISOLATE AND- OTHER THAN THEM
THEY HATE THE SOMETHING ELSE OR
DIFF DIFFERENT THINGS. SO WHY.
DO YOU THINK YOUR EX. WE'RE
GONNA CUT IT DOWN AND THEN I
WONDER JUST A COMING TO MY MIND.
OPPOSITE OF A HATE IS SO MAYBE
LOVE. MAYBE PROMOTING. THE THAT
THE BEAUTY OF A LOVER TWO
CHILDREN RATHER THAN NOT TO
HATE. AND HOW HOW DO YOU TRAIN
CHILDREN NOT TO HATE EACH OTHER.
BUT OPPOSITE R. BA L. IN A
SENSITIVITY AND THE BEAUTY OF
OUR LOVE IN A THAT MAY BE MORE
EFFECTIVE A HAVE YOU DONE ANY
STUDY IN THAT KIND OF THING
AREAS SO HOW TO REDUCE AND OF
WHAT THE METHODOLOGY HISTORY
YOU MAY PROPOSE. WHAT ARE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OFFEND. BY
ANYONE TO AMOL BUT I IT WAS I
THINK ENFORCEMENT HAVE HAD AN
IMPACT WHAT WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE IT AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING PIECES OF THE JIGSAW
PUZZLE NOT THE WHOLE PUZZLE.
BUT WE SAW A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN IN THE PROPERTY HATE
CRIMES FOR INSTANCE ALSO UP
WHEN WE HAVE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
PROMOTE TOLERANCE- I THINK THAT
CREATES A NICE ENVIRONMENT BUT
WITH WITH REGARD TO TRAINING
IT'S IMPERATIVE. THAT THESE
CASES ARE COMMON TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE IF THEY
DON'T WE SOMETIMES SEE THEM
OCCUR SEE REALLY WITH
ESCALATING A SEVERITY ALSO.
MENTAL HEALTH ON THERE A LOT
FOLKS WERE YOU KNOW THE HARD
CORE WHICH YOU'RE VERY SMALL
SLIVER OF OFFENDERS BUT THE
MAKE UP THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF THE HOMICIDAL
OFFENDERS. ON AND THE TALK
ABOUT ONCE THE REFORMED- THE
ONES THAT HAVE COMMITTED
VIOLENT CRIMES HOW THERE WAS NO
WAR FRAM FOR THEM TO GO WITH
NOTHING IN THEM THE MENTAL
HEALTH WORLD WHERE SOMEONE WHO
IS- DYED IN THE WOOL WHITE
SUPREMACIST TO GO. BUT WITH
REGARD TO- TO TRADITIONALLY
MOST HATE CRIMES WERE DONE BY
WHAT LEVIN THE MCDEVITT ANOTHER
WEAPON A COLD FOR REAL
OFFENDERS AND THEY HAVE VERY
SHALLOW PREJUDICES THEIR YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE OFTEN INTOXICATED
AND THEY'RE SEEKING PEER
VALIDATION. THOSE FOLKS ARE
WILL BE DETERRED BY THESE TYPES
OF CRIMES ABOUT THESE TYPES OF
STATUTE. THE MISSION OFFENDERS
THOSE PEOPLE ARE MUCH HARDER.
TO DISCOURAGE THEY HAVE TO BE
INTERDICTED AND IS GETTING
INCREASINGLY HARD BECAUSE WE
HAD A FRAGMENTED SOCIAL MEDIA
WERE FOLKS COMING TO THE TOP OF
THE FUNNEL AS A- PROFESSOR. WON
SAID AND THEN THEY GO DE INTO
THE RABBIT. WHICH IS INCREASE.
ON A STOVE PIPE SO WE'RE SEEING
FRANCES LIKED THE- ENCRYPTED
PLACES LIKE TELEGRAM HAD THE
SMALL SUB CULTURES OF. TWENTY
THIRTY FIFTY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE ARE ANY DAMAGED
ACROSS BORDERS SO THAT'S A
THAT'S A DIFFICULTY WE'RE
HAVING WE HAVE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF OFFENDERS FROM THE- THIS THE
SHALLOW PREJUDICES ALL THE WAY-
TO. MENTALLY ILL FOLKS AS WELL
AS WHAT WAS CALLED THE MISSION
OFFENDERS AND THOSE FOLKS ARE
INVOLVED IN WEAPONS PROCUREMENT
AND THEY BELIEVE THAT THEIR
WARRIORS OFFER THEIR GROUP AND
THEY WILL STOP. AT NOTHING
SHORT OF VIOLENCE. THANK YOU
THANK SO MUCH ONE WITH OF THE
PANEL. AND ALSO THE THIRD SAW
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. BROWN
FROM MIKE HERE WELL MOVING ON
TO THE NEXT I KNOW. WOULD THE
TWO WILL BE NOW. AND LOOK AHEAD.
EFFORTS WHO ADDRESS HATE CRIME
LIKE WILL COME CHRIS SON. IS
THIS AS TO ATTEND GENERAL AND
ALL MONEY WHILE ALVAREZ FROM
EXACT OF DURA FROM THE COMING
ON PEACE OFFERS DE AND- ON A
LOT BUT NOT. ALL THE WAY FOR
EPD ALTHOUGH MY- PLEASE JOIN.
ALL RIGHT WELL GO FIRST. A ON
BEHALF OF THE TOURNEY GENERAL
TO SERRA THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
PROVIDE YOU AN UPDATE ON OUR
CRITICAL WORK TO ADDRESS SOME
PREVENT A CRIMES IN OUR STATE.
ALSO WITH ME TODAY ARE MY
COLLEAGUES CHRIS RYAN THE CHIEF
OF THE DIVISION OF OPERATIONS
FOR DOJ. AND ELLISON LINDA FROM
DOJ SADISTIC CENTER. WE'LL BE
ABLE TO ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE AGREES
BUDGET FOR A CRIME PREVENTION
AND ABOUT DOJ'S COLLECTION AND
REPORTING OF HATE CRIME
STATISTICS. BUT BEFORE I BEGIN
I WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN CHIU
INSURANCE ALAS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM FOR THEIR
TIRELESS COMMITMENT TO HELPING
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
CAN THRIVE REGARDLESS OF WHO
THEY ARE WHOM THEY LOVE OR WHAT
LOOK WHAT RELIGION THEY
PRACTICE. A DOJ WE UNDERSTAND
THE CRIMES MOTIVATED BY HATE OR
NOT JUST ATTACKS ON INDIVIDUAL
INNOCENT PEOPLE. THEY ARE TAX
OR COMMUNITIES IN THE ENTIRE
STATE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
KNOW THAT DIVERSITY. IS OUR
STRENGTH. AND THAT ALL MEMBERS
ARE COMMUNITIES DESERVE TO FEEL
SAFE. THIS IS WHY DOJ HAS MADE
A CONCERTED EFFORT. TO HELP
INSURE HATE CRIMES OR
INVESTIGATED AND PROSECUTED.
AND TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
RESPONSES THE HIPPIES CONFLICT.
I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
DESCRIBE SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE SINCE THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. I WANT TO
KNOW THE DOJ TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING HATE CRIMES. AND
THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
DIVISIONS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
WORKING COORDINATION WITH ONE
ANOTHER ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THOSE DIVISIONS INCLUDE
THE CALIFORNIA JUSTICE
INFORMATIONS SERVICES. A OR
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SEIZURES THE
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
DALY AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT SECTION OR KRESS.
FIRST I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT
DOJ'S DATA COLLECTION REPORTING
EFFORTS. AS WE ALL AGREE
CORRECT REPORTING OF HATE
CRIMES TO DOJ IS ESSENTIAL TO
RAISING AWARENESS ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMBATING BIAS
MOTIVATED OFFENSES NATIONWIDE
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE NATURE
AND MAGNITUDE OF HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVING ACCURATE
DATA ABOUT WHEN AND WHERE HE
CRIMES ARE OCCURRING CAN HELP
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AS WELL
AS DOJ BETTER DIRECTOR
RESOURCES TO COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING THE MOST IMPACTED. OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS DOJ HAS
ENGAGED IN SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS
EFFORTS TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE
ARE RECEIVING ACCURATE DATA
FROM LAW ENFOREMENT AGENCIES.
OR ELEAZAR. THESE EFFORTS
INCLUDE ESTABLISHING A NEW
PROCEDURE WHERE WE PROACTIVELY
SEARCH FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT DATA TO US UNDER
PARAMETERS SET BY THE FBI.
UNDER THAT PROCEDURE WE
MAINTAIN A LIST OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY REPORTING
AGENCIES. AND I JUST WANT TO
NOTE HERE THAT IN TERMS OF
REPORTING AGENCIES THESE
PARAMETERS ARE SET. BY THE FBI
AND THEY'RE VERY SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS SO IT'S NOT AS IF
YOU CAN DO A GOOGLE SEARCH AND
DETERMINE OKAY WELL THESE ARE
ALL THE REPORTING AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S A MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED PROCESS. PROCESS
AND THAT. WE ALSO INSURE THAT
ALL OF THE AGENCIES ON THAT
LIST REPORT HATE CRIME DATA TO
WAS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
INDUSTRY GUIDANCE ON HATE
CRIMES REPORTING TO ALL. TO ALL
OF THE EARLY EIGHTIES ON THAT
LIST. SUBJECT TO AVAILABLE
STAFFING WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
MAKE PRESENTATIONS TO REPORTING
ELLIE ETS TO FACILITATE BUT- HE
CRIME IDENTIFICATION. AS
ADJUSTABLE REPORTING. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WE'VE
MADE A DOZEN PRESENTATIONS ON
IDENTIFICATION AND REPORTING.
OF HATE CRIMES THAT STATEWIDE A
REGIONAL CONFERENCES REACHING
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. THESE TRAINING
SUPPLEMENT THE REPORTING TOOLS
AND OTHER GUYS WE DISTRIBUTE TO
ELLIE ETS ON HOW TO ACCURATELY
REPORT HATE CRIMES AND EIGHT
INCIDENTS. WE ALSO OF
IMPLEMENTED NEW QUALITY CONTROL
EFFORTS FOR EACH HATE CRIMES A
MISSION TO HELP ENSURE ACCURATE
REPORTING. USING THE NEW
QUALITY CONTROL PROCESS FOR
EACH BE A CRIME REPORTED TO US
WE COMPARE THE UNDERLYING
INCIDENT REPORT WITH A HATE
CRIME STATISTICAL REPORTING
SUBMISSION. THIS IS PROVE
VALUABLE IN NOT ONLY IMPROVING
HATE CRIME REPORTING DID
INTEGRITY BUT ALSO IN
IDENTIFYING GAPS. FOR USE IN
DEVELOPING TRAINING MATERIALS.
IF YOU SCHOOL YEAR 200-019-2000
TWENTY DOJ RECEIVED FUNDING FOR
FIVE POSITIONS TO AUGMENT OUR
HATE CRIMES WORK. BECAUSE OF
THIS FUNDING WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HIRE A RESEARCHER TO TRACK AND
MONITOR FIRST HAND RESEARCH
RECEIVED FROM THE COMMUNITY
WHICH WILL BE USED TO DRAFT THE
ANNUAL HATE CRIMES REPORT-
ISSUED BY THE OJ. AND THE NEXT-
HATE CRIMES REPORT FOR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SO DISTRICTS
WILL COME OUT IN JULY TWENTY
TWENTY. AMONG THE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS OF THE RESEARCHERS
WORKING ON IS THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A DASHBOARD FOR THE DOJ OPEN
JUST AS WEBSITE. THEY ALLOW
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO PRODUCE
MEANINGFUL. STATISTICS AND EASY
TO UNDERSTAND VISUALISATIONS OF
HATE CRIMES USING DATA. WE'RE
ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING
FOR ADDITIONAL POSITION TO
AUGMENT THE HATE CRIME
IDENTIFICATION TRAINING EFFORTS
THAT I MENTIONED. THESE
POSITIONS ALSO ASSIST IN
PREPARING IN COORDINATING THE
DISTRIBUTION OF ADVISORY
BULLETINS AND ASSISTING WITH
THE QUALITY CONTROL FUNCTIONS
FOR HATE CRIME DATA SUBMITTED
BY THE- RESPECTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. ONE THING
I WANT TO NOTE IS THAT WHY WE
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR THE
FIVE POSITIONS AND ARE
CONFIDENT THEIR WORK WORK WILL
HELP IMPROVE THE INTEGRITY OF
THE DATA WE COLLECT. THE
REMAINS ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT.
WE BELIEVE THAT IN ADDITION OF
AN ATTORNEY. TO THIS TEAM
BECAUSE SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCE
OUR WORK THE TOURNEY WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUT REACH AND
COORDINATION BETWEEN AMONG
HUMAN RIGHTS AND HUMAN
RELATIONS COMMISSIONS SCHOOL
OFFICIALS ADVOCATES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS ISSUES REQUIRING LEGAL
ANALYSIS. IN TERMS OF IMPROVING
IMPROVING DOJ'S HATE CRIMES
DATABASE. AS MENTIONED BEFORE-
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRANSITIONING TO THE F. B. I.'S
NATIONAL INCIDENT BASED
REPORTING SYSTEM OR NEIGHBORS.
OR CURRENTLY ON TRACK TO BE
NEIGHBORS CERTIFIED BY THE END
OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR AND READY
TO ACCEPT DATA ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ONCE THE
TRANSITION TO NEIGHBORS OCCURS
OR OR VERSION OF IT WHICH IS
CALLED FIBERS. WILL BE ABLE TO
COLLECT AND REPORT ON MANY
ADDITIONAL ELEMENTS OF EACH
CRIMINAL INCIDENT. INCLUDING
REGION SPECIFIC INFORMATION
SUCH AS ZIP CODE. HAVING MORE
IN DEPTH DATA ABOUT HATE CRIME
INCIDENTS WILL HELP US CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE OUR EFFORTS TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL PATTERNS HOT
SPOTS. CROSS JURISDICTIONAL
INCIDENTS AND DISTRIBUTE
NOTICES TO THE RELEVANT ELLIE
ETS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS. NEXT
I'M GONNA DISCUSS SOME OF THE
WORK BEING DONE BY DOJ'S
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
FIRST AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
AUDITOR WERE WORKING TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE TOURNEY
GENERAL'S HATE CRIME RAPID
RESPONSE TEAM. FOR THOSE OF
YOUR LESS FAMILIAR WITH THE
RAPID RESPONSE TEAM THE TEAM IS
COMPOSED OF DOJ SENIOR
OFFICIALS WHO CAN ACT QUICKLY
TO ASSIST LOCAL AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AUTHORITIES IN THE
IDENTIFICATION ARREST
PROSECUTION AND CONVICTION OF
THE PERPETRATORS OF HATE
CRIMES. THE TEAM IS ON CALL AT
ALL TIMES. IT'S IMPORTANT OVER
THE DOJ FUNDS THE RESPONSE
TEAM. THEIR EXISTIN RESOURCES
IF A TRIGGERING EVENT OCCURRED
THE DOJ WOULD ASSEMBLE
PERSONNEL TO HANDLE THE
SITUATION WITH THE EXISTING
RESOURCES. HOWEVER IF DEMAND
INCREASED IT WOULD NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO PROVIDE
MORE SYSTEMS TO ELLIE ACE. IN
RESPONSE TO THE AUDITOR'S
CONCERNS THAT THERE WAS
INSUFFICIENT AWARENESS OF THE
OJ RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
COMBAT HATE CRIMES THE DOJ
UPDATED ITS HATE CRIME RAPID
RESPONSE PROTOCOL. WHICH
INCLUDED AND INFORMATION
BULLETIN AND A BROCHURE IN
FOURTEEN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED TO
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS AND
THROUGH A PRESS RELEASE. IN MAY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
LAUNCHED A NEW HATE CRIMES
PREVENTION WEBPAGE OFFERING THE
PUBLIC AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AN
ONLINE PLATFORM TO VIEW
RESOURCES AND IN FOR IMPORTANT
INFORMATION. THROUGH DEALEY LAW
BULLETINS THAT ARE SENT TO ALL
ELEAZAR WE ALSO WORK TO INFORM
ELEAZAR WILL HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AT THE OJ. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FOR EXAMPLE
DEAL YOU ISSUED A LAW BULLETIN
DESCRIBING ALL THE PENAL CODE
SECTIONS RELATED HATE CRIMES.
AS WELL STATUTES LIKE THE RALPH
ACT IN THE BEING ACT. THE GREAT
CIVIL PENALTIES FOR BIAS
MOTIVATED UNLAWFUL BEHAVIOR.
JUST RECENTLY IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE ISSUED A
BULLETIN THAT INFORMED ELLIE IS
BOTH THE ENACTMENT OF AB IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE. WHICH
AMONG OTHER THINGS CLARIFY THE
DISABILITY IS PROTECTED UNDER
THE LAW REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
IS TEMPORARY PERMANENT
CONGENITAL ACQUIRED BY HEREDITY
ACCIDENT ADVANCED AGE OR
ILLNESS. FINALLY DISCUSS
BRIEFLY THE WORK BEING DONE
BARS CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT
SECTION TO ENGAGE IN OUTREACH
TO LOCAL HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSIONS AND ADVOCACY GROUPS
REGARDING HATE CRIMES AND HATE
INCIDENTS. DESPITE LACK OF
DEDICATED FUNDING OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE OJ ATTORNEYS
HAVE ATTENDED AND GIVING
PRESENTATIONS ORIGINAL HATE
CRIME CONVENING SO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
ADVOCATES. MOST RECENTLY OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT
SECTION PRESENTED AT A TRAINING
THAT WAS ORGANIZED BY THE LA
COUNTY COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RELATIONS IN SEPTEMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. CROSS ALSO
REGULARLY ATTENDS THE QUARTERLY
NETWORK AGAINST HATE CRIMES
HOSTED BY THE COMMISSION. THOSE
MEETINGS USUALLY INVOLVE
REPRESENTATIVES OF VARIOUS
FEDERAL STATE COUNTY CITY
ENTITIES LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES NONPROFITS ANOTHER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS. AS I
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED WITH
DEDICATED FUNDING WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ENHANCE THOSE OUTREACH
EFFORTS WE COULD ALSO MORE
MEANING FULLY ENGAGE WITH LOCAL
AND REGIONAL HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSIONS AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. SO IN SUMMARY
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ON IT DOJ HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES ENSURING
THAT WE'RE RECEIVING ACCURATE
DATA FROMLAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ON HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU'VE HEARD
WE'VE MADE NUMEROUS TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT ON
HOW TO BETTER IDENTIFY YOUR
REPORT HE CRIMES WE'VE ALSO
REACHED OUT TO LEASE THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE. ELEAZAR
AS PART OF OUR IN PERSON
TRAINING EFFORTS AND ONE ON ONE
OUT REACH. IN ADDITION BASED ON
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVED WE'VE
HIRED A RESEARCHER THAT WILL
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH GUIDANCE RELATED
TO HATE CRIME ANALYSIS
INTERPRETATION REPORTING. AN
OUT REACH WE'RE WORKING TO
RECRUIT IN THE ON BOARD FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF AT CEDARS TO
AUGMENT THE DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING EFFORTS WITH ELEAZAR.
WE'VE ALSO WORK DILIGENTLY TO
ENSURE THE LEDS ARE AWARE OF
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE FROM
THE DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
THROUGH THE DOJ HATE CRIMES
VENTURE WEBSITE AND
DISTRIBUTION OF LAW BULLETINS
AND OTHER MATERIALS. AND
FINALLY DESPITE THE LACK OF ANY
DEDICATED FUNDING ATTORNEYS
FROM OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT SECTION HAVE
PARTICIPATED. IN AT LEAST READ
EIGHT REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE
CONVENING OF COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES AND LOCAL OFFICIALS.
IF DOJ WERE TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WE CAN
STRENGTHEN ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
AND DO MORE TO INCREASE
ENGAGEMENT WITH VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND WITH HUMAN
RELATIONS COMMISSIONS AND LOCAL
TASK FORCE ON HATE CRIMES. LIKE
THE ONE ESTABLISHED THIS PAST
FALL BY THE SANTA CLARA BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. AND AS ALWAYS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENHANCE OUR
EFFORTS IN ADDRESSING HATE
CRIMES IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO MISTER
ALVAREZ I WANTED TO RECOGNIZE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BORN IN OR BEST
USE JOINING US AND ALSO-
SENATOR SCOTT WINNER WAS HERE
EARLIER. AND PUT A JOIN US
BRIEFLY. MISTER ALVAREZ. I'M
SORRY QUESTION HOW WHO REALLY
GOING. CAN WE WAIT UNTIL ALL
THE PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN CHIU AND- CHAIR SALAS
ALL MEMBERS OF THE STAFF AND ON
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AT THE HEARING. MY NAME
IS MANNY ALVAREZ AND I SERVE AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING OR POST
HIS WE ARE COMMONLY KNOWN. POST
IS COMPRISED OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SERVE TH NEEDS OF THE STATE BY
SETTING HIRING STANDARDS.
DELIVERING TRAINING. SETTING
REGULATIONS AND CONDUCTING
AUDITS FOR FORTY ONE POLICE
ACADEMIES AND SIX HUNDRED NINE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHICH
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE OPPOSE
PROGRAM. APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUEIGHTY THREE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED FULL TIME PEACE
OFFICERS AND EIGHT THOUSAND
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHERS
CURRENTLY FALL UNDER THE POST
PROGRAM. AS I NOTED IN
TESTIMONY A SIMILAR HEARING IN
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN CESAR
HOW AND STE AND HER STAFF NOTED
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS FOR POST IN
HER REPORT OF MAY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TITLED HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA. LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
NOT ADEQUATELY IDENTIFIED
REPORTED AND RESPONDED TO HATE
CRIMES I WON'T READ THE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS SINCE THEY WERE
READ- EARLIER IN THE DAY BY THE
STATE HONORING HER STAFF. POST
POST ACCEPTED THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS SINCE MY
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY POST
REPORTED TO THE STATE AUDITOR
ON THE PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING
THE TWO RECOMMENDATIONS. POSES
COMPLETED THE WORK ON THE TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND THE STATE
AUDITOR HAS ACCEPTED THE
WORKING CLOSE BOTH
RECOMMENDATIONS. WITH THE
PASSAGE OF LEGISLATION IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE UPDATED THE
POST HATE CRIMES MODEL POLICY
GUIDE. THE ORIGINAL HATE CRIMES
GUIDELINES WERE PUBLISHED IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT. THE NEW GUIDELINES
REP DATED PURSUANT TO
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE SECTION
FOR TWENTY TWO POINT EIGHT
SEVEN. AND ONE THREE FIVE ONE
NINE POINT SIXTY. THE WORK ON
THE NEW GUIDELINES STARTED IN
OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND
CULMINATED WITH THEIR
PUBLICATION AND DISTRIBUTION TO
ALL POSTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ON JULY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. THE HATE
CRIME GUIDELINES CAN BE FOUND
ON THE ON THE POST PUBLIC
WEBSITE. CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE
SECTION ONE THREE FIVE ONE NINE
POINT SIX SEE REQUIRE STATE
AGENCIES TO INCORPORATE THE
CONTENT OF THE NEW GUIDELINES.
SHOULD AGENCIES DECIDE TO
VOLUNTARILY UPDATE THEIR HATE
CRIMES- POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS.
POST IS NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
INDIVIDUAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY POLICIES AND AS SUCH WE
DO NOT TRACK POLICIES NOR DO WE
TRACK WHEN AGENCIES UPDATE
THEIR POLICIES. THEREFORE POST
CANNOT SPEAK TO HOW MANY
AGENCIES HAVE ADOPTED THE NEW
TWENTY NINETEEN HATE CRIMES
GUIDELINES. I WANT TO THANK THE
FOLLOWING GROUPS AND AGENCIES
FOR HELPING US CREATE AN UPDATE
THE NEW GUIDELINES THE END OF
LACI P. THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE. WE ARE CALIFORNIA
MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE
AND EDUCATIONAL FUND ISLAMIC
NETWORKS SACRAMENTO DA'S OFFICE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
THE TURLOCK POLICE DEPARTMENT
THE NAPA VALLEY NAPA VALLEY
COLLEGE. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CSU SAN BERNADINO AND UC DAVIS.
ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO THANK
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE NOT ONLY
FOR THEIR CALL COLLABORATION ON
THE POST HATE CRIMES GUIDELINES
PROJECT BUT ALSO FOR INCLUDING
POST AND SOME OF THEIR OWN
RELATED MEETINGS WITH VARIOUS
HATE CRIMES ADVOCACY GROUPS. IN
TERMS OF HATE HATE CRIMES
TRAINING POST HAS SEVERAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS FROM THE
BASIC ACADEMY FOR NEW PEACE
OFFICER RECRUITS. AND
INSTRUCTION FOR ENTRY LEVEL
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHERS. POST
ALSO HAS IN SERVICE TRAINING
FOR BOTH PEACE OFFICERS AND
DISPATCHERS. FIRST IN THE PEACE
OFFICER BASIC ACADEMY OR WITH
OTHERS CALL THE POLICE ACADEMY
ALL NEW RECRUITS AND CADETS
RECEIVE A MINIMUM OF SIXTEEN
HOURS OF TRAINING ON POST
LEARNING DOMAIN FORTY FORTY TWO
CULTURAL DIVERSITY. THE BLACK
OF INSTRUCTION INCLUDES VARIOUS
GROUP OR ANY ACTIVITIES AND
COVERS SUCH TOPICS AS
RECOGNIZING DIVERSITY PREJUDICE
DISCRIMINATION AND RACIAL
PROFILING. EFFECTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONTACTS SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
FURTHERMORE CHAPTER FIVE OF
THIS LEARNING DOMAIN IS
DEDICATED EXCLUSIVELY TO HATE
CRIMES AND INCLUDES THE%
FOLLOWING TOPICS. OVERVIEW OF
HATE CRIMES LAWS RELATED TO
HATE CRIMES FEDERAL AND CIVIL
ACTIONS RELATED TO HATE CRIMES
IMPACT OF HATE CRIMES. AND
INVESTIGATION AND DOCUMENTING
DOCUMENTATION OF HATE CRIMES.
AS MENTIONED ONLY PEACE OFFICER
RECRUITS RECEIVE THIS TRAINING
FOR CONTACTS WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
OVER FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
GRADUATING FROM CALIFORNIA
POLICE ACADEMIES EACH YEAR.
ASIDE FROM THE MANDATED HATE
CRIMES TRAINING IN THE BASIC
CATTERY. ALL OTHER IN SERVICE
HATE CRIMES TRAINING FOR
EXISTING OFFICERS IS VOLUNTARY.
POST OFFERS VARIOUS HATE CRIMES
TRAINING COURSES FOR IN SERVICE
OFFICERS. FOR INSTANCE POST
PARTNERS WITH THE MUSEUM OF
TOLERANCE TO DELIVER CULTURAL
DIVERSITY AND HATE CRIMES
TRAINING. EACH YEAR POST SIGNED
A ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
TRAINING CONTRACT WITH THE
MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE FOR TEN
POST CERTIFIED TRAINING COURSES
INCLUDING ONE COURSE TITLE HATE
CRIME INVESTIGATION FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS. THIS COURSE MEETS
YOUR- REQUIREMENTS ENUMERATED
IN CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE
SECTION ONE THREE FIVE ONE NINE
POINT SIX. PEACE OFFICERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHERS ALSO
RECEIVED HATE CRIMES AND
CULTURAL DIVERSITY TRAINING
DURING VOLUNTARY PARTICIPATION
IN THE EIGHT MONTH. POST
SUPERVISORY LEADERSHIP
INSTITUTE OR WHAT WE CALL SLI.
THE SLI PROGRAM INCLUDE SIXTEEN
HOURS OF TRAINING BY THE MUSEUM
OF TOLERANCE. HISTORICALLY
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERGEANTS HAVE
COMPLETED SLI TRAINING EACH
YEAR. HOWEVER DURING THIS
FISCAL YEAR WE ANTICIPATE
HAVING A TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
SERGEANTS AND FIFTY PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS PARTICIPATE
IN SLI TRAINING. TRAINING
DELIVERED BY THE MUSEUM OF
TOLERANCE IS EXCEPTIONAL AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP. AS I MENTIONED
DURING HEARING IN AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN POST HAS TO HAS A TWO
HOUR VIDEO BASED ONLINE
TRAINING COURSE TITLED HATE
CRIMES. THE TRAINING WAS
ORIGINALLY RELEASED AGENCIES IN
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
VIA DVD AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THE COURSE IS PLACED ON THE
POST LEARNING PORTAL SO COULD
BE STREAM TO INDIVIDUAL USERS.
SINCE THE COURSE WAS RELEASED-IN NOVEMBER. TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE RECEIVED
CREDIT FOR COMPLETING THE TO
OUR COURSE OF INSTRUCTION. POST
HAS ALSO BEEN WORKING ON TO.
DID YOU KNOW VIDEOS ON HATE
CRIMES. POSTED YOU KNOW VIDEOS
ARE GENERALLY ABOUT THREE
MINUTES LONG AND ARE CREATED TO
SHOW DURING PATROL BRIEFINGS
TRAININGS AND COMMUNITY
MEETINGS. DID YOU KNOW Vì
VIDEOS ARE NOT CONSIDERED
TRAINING AND INSTEAD ARE PER
CREEK ARE PRODUCED TO CREATE
DISCUSSION. DID YOU KNOW VIDEOS
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR LEARNING
PORTAL AS WELL AS ON OUR PUBLIC
WEBSITE. THE PRODUCTION AND
REVIEW OF BOTH VIDEOS AS SUCH.
EXCUSE ME ESSENTIALLY COMPLETE.
AND WE ANTICIPATE THE FIRST
VIDEO TO BE RELEASED IN THE
NEXT THIRTY DAYS FOLLOWED BY
THE RELEASE OF THE SECOND VIDEO
IN THE NEXT SIXTY TO NINETY
DAYS. POST HAS TO THE POST HAS
TO LEGACY COURSES UNDER THE
ROBERT PRESSLEY INSTITUTE OF
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION WHICH
INCLUDE INSTRUCTION ON HATE
CRIMES SPECIFIC DOMESTIC
TERRORISM COURSE AND THE
TERRORISM INVESTIGATORS SPOTS
COURSE IN MID TWENTY NINETEEN
POST ISSUED A ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT TO
THE ISLAMIC NETWORKS GROUP FOR
DELIVERY OF CULTURAL DIVERSITY
TRAINING FOR PEACE OFFICERS.
THIS ADVOCACY GROUPS TRAINING
CURRICULUM HAS RECENTLY BEEN
CERTIFIED BY POST AND DELIVERY
WILL OF THE TRAINING IS
EXPECTED TO START SOON THE
CULTURAL DIVERSITY CURRICULUM
DEVELOPED BY ISLAMIC NETWORKS
INCLUDE INSTRUCTION ON THE
TOPIC OF HATE CRIMES. ASIDE
FROM THE TRAINING I ALREADY
MENTIONED THERE ARE CURRENTLY
SIX COURSES IN THE POPE POST
CATALOG WHICH ARE SPECIFIC HATE
CRIMES COURSES WERE HAVE HATE
CRIMES COMPONENTS BUILT INTO
THE CURRICULUM. THESE TRAINING
COURSES ARE CERTIFIED TO THE
PALM SPRINGS POLICE DEPARTMENT
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. SAN VERDADEIRO
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT NAPA
VALLEY VALLEY COLLEGE AND THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS BASIC COURSE IS
REQUIRED FOR ALL ENTRY LEVEL
DISPATCHERS DISPATCHERS RECEIVE
A MINIMUM OF TWELVE HOURS OF
TRAINING ON POST LEARNING
DOMAIN ONE OH SEVEN. COMMUNITY
POLICING CULTURAL DIVERSITY
HATE CRIMES AND GANG AWARENESS
THE HATE CRIMES TRAINING IS
MODELED AFTER THE PEACE OFFICER
TRAINING AND INCLUDE SUCH
THINGS AS A RELEVANT SECTIONS
OF THE PENAL CODE. INCLUDING
INSTRUCTION ON THE
IDENTIFICATION OF A HATE CRIME.
AS MENTIONED ABOVE WE HAVE
EIGHT THOUSAND PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF THEM ARE
MANDATED TO RECEIVE THIS
TRAINING TO THE DURING THE
FIRST YEAR OF EMPLOYMENT.
LASTLY ALTHOUGH MY COMMENTS
WERE GEARED TOWARDS. YOUR TO
HATE CRIMES. I BRIEFLY TOUCHED
ON SOME OF THE POST TRAINING
COURSES RELATED TO CULTURAL
DIVERSITY. AS A RESULT I THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT TO MENTION.
CULTURAL DIVERSITY AND THE POST
INNOVATIVE GRANT PROGRAM. A
THREE YEAR PROGRAM TO TRAIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
ESTABLISHED DURING FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
PURSUANT TO A PENAL CODE
SECTION THIRTEEN FIVE OH NINE.
UNDER THIS PROGRAM TRAINING
GRANTS ARE AWARDED IN AMOUNTS
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND TO
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND AND ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE OF FIVE
AREAS. IS IT BIAS USE OF FORCE
IN DE ESCALATION. CULTURAL
DIVERSITY IN AWARENESS.
COMMUNITY POLICING AND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
EARLIER IN MY TESTIMONY TO
CULTURAL DIVERSITY GRANT HI
EARLIER IN MY TESTIMONY I
MENTIONED THE CULTURAL
DIVERSITY GRANT ISSUED TO THE
ISLAMIC NETWORKS GROUP.
CULTURAL DIVERSITY GRANTS WERE
ALSO AWARDED TO INNOVATION
SYSTEM SOLUTION. NATIONAL
CONFLICT RESOLUTION CENTER AND
GOLDEN WEST COLLEGE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TRAINING CENTER.
ANOTHER GRANT WAS ISSUED TO THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGIONAL
TRAINING CENTER. AND THIS
ENTITY IS MAKING MODIFICATIONS
TO THEIR BLOCK OF INSTRUCTION
TO ADDRESS RACIAL PROFILING AND
CULTURAL COMPETENCY. DURING THE
THIRD AND FINAL ROUND OF
FUNDING THE CULTURAL DIVERSITY
GRANT WAS AWARDED TO THE AUTISM
SOCIETY INLAND EMPIRE TO
CONDUCT LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING FOR INTERACTING WITH
PERSONS WITH AUTISM AND
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. IN TOTAL POST
ISSUED SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GRANTS
TO THE SIX ENTITIES. IN CLOSING
I WANT TO THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
FOR GRANTING POST THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AT THIS
HEARING. AND I ALSO AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LAST BUT NOT LEAST
FOR HOW WELL WE P. THE- MISTER
MARTINEZ CHAIR CHIU CHAIR SALAS
MY NAME IS ON A MARTINEZ A THE
LAPD'S HATE CRIME COORDINATOR.
MINE WILL BE MUCH SHORTER. I'M
WE- COMPLETED OUR STATISTICAL
REVIEW FOR TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
HATE CRIMES HAVE INCREASED- TEN
POINT 3% SINCE LAST YEAR SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN IT'S ABOUT 40%
INCREASE EACH YEAR IS
INCREMENTALLY GOING UP ACROSS
ALL CATEGORIES- ONE THINGS AT.
AT LAPD WE DO TAKE HATE
INCIDENT REPORTS- EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE NON CRIMINAL REPORTS
WE TAKE THEM TO USE THEM TO
TRACK TRENDS- WE CAN USE THEM-
AS EVIDENCE OF MOTIVATION FOR
SUSPECTS THAT ARE LATER
ARRESTED. THIS YEAR OUR HATE
CRIMES DID NOT INCREASE WE HAD
THE SAME NUMBER AS WE HAD IN-
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- SOME EXAMPLES
OF HATE INCIDENTS ARE-
DISPLAYING A **** FLAG WITHIN
YOUR OWN HOME THE ACADEMIC TERM
OF HATE SPEECH IS NOT A LEGAL
TERM SO. ST SEPTIMUS OFFENSIVE
BUT NOT A CRIMINAL ACT WE
WOULD- TAKE REPORTS ON THOSE IN
TRACK THOSE- AT THE UCBCP- TO
SHORE COMMITMENT FOR HATE CRIME
INVESTIGATIONS WE HAVE TWENTY
ONE GEOGRAPHIC DIVISIONS AND
FOUR BUREAUS AND EACH DIVISION
WE HAVE TO HATE CRIME
DETECTIVES. AND ADD SPIRO WE
HAVE ONE. I'M COORDINATOR SO WE
HAVE ABOUT FORTY SEVEN HE CRIME
DETECTIVES THROUGHOUT THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. WE'VE ALSO
CHANGED THE WAY THAT WE LIAISON
WITH THE COMMUNITY WE HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE- WE HAVE CHANGED THE
LIAISON FROM THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY TO. FROM THE
TERRORISM BUREAU TO OUR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT GROUP-
WE'RE TRYING TO. AS WITH THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS WE'RE
USING THE VICTIM CENTERED
APPROACH ON HATE CRIME VICTIMS.
GETTING ENSURING THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR NEEDS MET- JUST
AS IMPORTANT AS INVESTIGATING
THE CRIME. GIRLS PROVIDING FREE
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS TO A
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS AND
ADVOCACY GROUPS THAT REQUESTED
AND WE ALSO FOR THE FOR THE
GRANT PROGRAM WE SHOW THEM HOW
TO COMPLETE- CORRECTLY COMPLETE
COMPLETE THE GRANT INFORMATION.
FROM KERRY TUCKED BUT THAT- WE
CREATED SEVERAL WORKGROUPS WITH
THE COMMUNITY TO- IMPROVE OUR
RELATIONSHIPS AND THAT IS WHERE
OUR HATE CRIMES SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT CAME OUT OF THOSE OUT OF
AB WORK GROUP THAT INVOLVE THE
COMMUNITY AND PLEASE-
DEPARTMENT MEMBERS THEY CAME UP
WITH THE IDEA FOR THAT.
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT. I'M
POLICING HAS CHANGED- WE DON'T
PLEASE STOCKS WE POLICE
BEHAVIOR ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT CROSS HATE CRIMES GET
MISCLASSIFIED IS BECAUSE PEOPLE
THINK OF THEM AS HATE CRIMES. A
HATE CRIME IS FILING SOMEONE
CIVIL RIGHTS BECAUSE OF A
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTIC THAT
VERY VERY VERY RARELY OCCURS
UNLESS AND IN CALIFORNIA WHAT
OCCURS IS A BIAS MOTIVATED
CRIME AND THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE
THE PROBLEM. SO THE PENAL CODE
SAYS THAT. EITHER IN WHOLE OR
IN PART THE BIAS MOTIVATION
MUST BE PART OF WHY THE CRIME
OCCURRED THE JURY INSTRUCTIONS-
CASE LAW SAYS IT MUST BE A
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR BUT THAT'S
ALL IT SAYS. IS 1% ENOUGH IS 5%
ENOUGH DOES HAVE TO BE 51%
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE THE ISSUE
WE HAVE CRIMES THAT ARE BIASED
MOTIVATED THAT GET MISS CARE
CATEGORY. CATEGORIZED SUCH AS A
AN ARGUMENT OVER A PARKING SPOT.
TWO PEOPLE GET OUT OF THE CAR
START YELLING AT EACH OTHER ONE
SPEECH ON THE OTHER YOU HAVE A
BATTERY THE PERSON WHO SPENT
NOW WALKS AWAY AND THROWS A
RACIAL SLUR. AT THE VICTIM.
WHAT IS THAT. A SUBSTANTIAL
FACTOR IN THE COMMISSION OF A
CRIME. SO THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
THE I CAN US TEN PEOPLE THAT
QUESTION AND I'LL GET. PROBABLY
FIVE DIFFERENT ANSWERS SO
THAT'S WHY THAT WERE HAVING THE
ISSUES WITH THE REPORTS. TRYING
TO COME UP WITH THE TRAINING
THAT IS CONSISTENT. FOR
THIRTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES THE
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT. THAT
WILL EXPLAIN THOSE TYPES OF
INCIDENTS WHICH ARE 99% OF OUR
INCIDENTS IN LOS ANGELES WE DO
NOT HAVE THE. THE WHITE
SUPREMACIST- CRIMES. FOR THE
MOST PART GOING ON IT'S- ONE ON
ONE STRANGER ON STRANGER THOSE
ARE THE ONES THAT WE ARE
MISSING CATEGORY CATEGORIZING.
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN- THE
ODD SO. MY LAST POINT IS- SINCE
THE SHERRY WENT OVER WHAT THE
AUDIT STATED TO MY LAST POINT
IS. AT THE LAPD WE HAVE BEEN
IMPROVING FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS AND ARE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WHERE PARTNERING
WITH COMMUNITY WERE REACHING
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY. THE
PROBLEM WE'RE HAVING IS WE'RE
ONLY REACHING OUT TO HALF. WE
HAVE NOT FOUND IN EFFECTIVE WAY
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
OFFENDERS. PO PRE OFFENSE. TO
IDENTIFY ITS NOT LIKE GANG
INTERVENTION WHERE YOU CAN GO
INTO A NEIGHBORHOOD TALK TO THE
KIDS SHOW THEM THERE'S OTHER
WAYS THESE ARE ON LINE MOST
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE-
THAT LEARNED AT HOME OR AT
SCHOOL OR SOMEWHERE ELSE. HOW
TO PEOPLE AREN'T BORN HATING
BABY LEARN THIS AND IDENTIFYING
THAT AND COMING UP WITH THE
PROGRAM THIS EFFECTIVE FOR
POLICE IN MY CASE TO TRY TO
HELP AND CHANGE THAT I THINK
THEY WERE DOING MUCH BETTER
WITH THE COMMUNITY OF COURSE
THERE'S WORK TO DO BUT FINDING
PROGRAMS TO. GET THE IF THERE'S
BEFORE THEY BECOME OFFENDERS IS
WHAT THE I. P. NEEDS TO WORK ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- RUDY DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANEL YES PLEASE IF I MAY- THIS
COUPLE QUESTIONS BASED OFF YOUR
TESTIMONY AND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER WE START THERE WE-
START WITH THE FIRST ONE. BUT
WELL LET'S JUST START WITH A
MISTER MARTINEZ OF WE CAN'T.
HEAR YOU TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF ERRORS AND A NUMBER OF
ERRORS WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE
AUDIT FROM LAPD FOR INSTANCE
NOW IS IT MOSTLY BECAUSE OF.
THE PARKING SPOT INCIDENT THE
SHOCKING ABOUT THAT YOU KNOW
WHETHER WE SHOULD COST FOR THAT
IS A GREAT I I'LL GIVE YOU. ONE
OF THE ACTORS ONE OF THE HEIRS
WILL. ACE A STUDENT AT A TOOL
FOR OUT AS IF. IF HE DID NOT
MOVE OUT OF THE WAY HE WOULD BE
BETTER. BECAUSE OF HIS GLORY.
SO HE MISSED CLASS THAT BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T BELIEVE IT WAS ENOUGH.
TO BECAUSE HIS FEELING OF IT.
THE SUSPECTS NEVER EXPRESSED IT.
IN SO DOJ BELIEVE THAT THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AT THE TIME WE
DIDN'T THINK IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN BUT IS THAT TYPE OF
INCIDENT IT'S NOT THE SWASTIKA
IT'S NOT THE- CALLING A SLUR
AND THEN HITTING SOMEBODY IT'S
THE BATES NUMBERS THAT WERE
THAT WERE HAVING ISSUES WITH.
OKAY SO IT'S NOT A LACK OF
SUPPORT OF THE INCIDENCES IS
JUST THE CLASSIFICATION. OF
THEM MY GUESS IS. WHERE THE AIR
IS YES WHAT FOR THE ON THE
PLEASE DEPARTMENTS PART YES SO
THERE IS CHEN THERE IS UNDER
REPORTING FROM THE PUBLIC AND
THAT IS BECAUSE OF OUR DECADES
LONG WHEN I WHEN I STARTED WE
WERE AN OCCUPYING FORCE. WE
WANTED THEM TO FERRIS THAT'S
NOT THE WAY IT IS ANYMORE MMHM
WE TRIED TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
WE'RE WE'RE DOING WAY BETTER
THAN WE WERE. BUT IT TAKES TIME
TO BUILD THAT TRUST WITH
COMMUNITY WE'RE WORKING HARD TO
DO IT AND- AS THE IF YOU LOOK
AT OUR STATS YOU'LL SEE THAT
ACROSS ALL THE PROTECT THE
CHARACTER. SIX THE PERCENTAGE
GOING UP THEY THEY KIND OF
MATCH EACH OTHER. SO THAT LEADS
US TO BELIEVE THAT IT'S OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS NOT SPATE OF.
CRIMES AGAINST A CERTAIN
COMMUNITY IS THAT THEY'RE
TRUSTING US MORE THINKING WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
WE'RE GOING TO INVESTIGATE IT
AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM. SO AS OPPOSED TO WHAT WE
USED TO GOT IT GOT IT THAT
MAKES SENSE AND FOR THE
REPORTING SO YOU KNOW YOU GIVE
TWO EXAMPLES NOW AND I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- THEY THEN
JUST JUDGMENT CALLS BY THE
OFFICERS IT'S RESPONDING OR IS
IT YOU KNOW THIS THE QUESTION I
HAD FOR DOJ WAS YOU KNOW THE
AUDIT ALSO IDENTIFIED THE LACK
OF COMING UP CLEAR GUIDELINES
OUR BEST PRACTICES DOES IT.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
GUIDELINES AND CLEAR PRACTICES
BABY FROM DOJ OR IS IT THE YOU
KNOW JUDGMENT CALLS OF THE
OFFICER RESPONDING TO AN
INCIDENT OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. THAT GAP. I BELIEVE IT'S
COMBINATION. SO WE ARE UPDATING
OUR WE'RE VOLUNTARILY UPDATING
OUR HE KIND POLICY AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE ADDING IN
IS WE HAVE FIVE LEVELS A REVIEW
FOR EVERY REPORT. SO THAT WE
DON'T MISS IT. BEFORE IT WAS
TOO. IT WAS THE PERSON WHO
ENTERED INTO THE SYSTEM AND THE
SERGEANT WHO READ THE REPORT
NOW WE'VE ADDED THREE EXTRA
LAYERS SO THAT. HOPEFULLY
SOMEBODY CATCHES IT I'M I'M
SURE WHEN I CAN BE PERFECT
HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY CATCHES IT
CORRECTS IT ANOTHER THING THAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE ARE- WE
COMMITTED TO THE TO BEING
TRANSPARENT SO WE HAVE THIS
OPEN DATA THING- SO. ANY TIME
THAT THE REPORT GETS CODED INTO
THE SYSTEM IT'S AUTOMATICALLY
POPULATED ON THE WEBSITE SO
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN SEE. WHAT'S
GOING ON WHEN IT HAPPENS IF
SOMETHING GETS RE CLASSIFIED TO
OR FROM THEY CAN INQUIRE AS TO
WHY BUT IT GETS UPDATED REAL
TIME TRYING TO BE TRANSPARENT-
SO THAT WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT CAN BOOKS GOT IT. ONE
COMMENT WRITE ON ON THE DO SIDE
AS A MENTIONED WE HAVE- SINCE
THE AUDIT- INSTITUTE A NEW
QUALITY CONTROL PROCESS BY
WHICH WE REQUIRE ALL THE
UNDERLYING INCIDENT REPORTS TO
BE SUBMITTED TO US- SO THAT WE
CAN. DETERMINE HOW HATE CRIMES
ARE BEING REPORTED AND IF
THEY'RE BEING REPORTED
CORRECTLY SO JUST GOING BACK TO
THE ISSUES THAT THE JUDGMENT
CALL. I THINK THE NUMBER OF
SCARY AS THE THAT FOLKS COULD
IN THE ROOM COULD COME UP WITH
ARE INFINITE RIGHT AND SO I
THINK. HAVING THAT INFORMATION
THE UNDERLYING INCIDENT REPORT
SEEING HOW THEY'RE BEING CODED
AND SEEING IF THERE ANY TRENDS.
ABOUT MAYBE- YOU KNOW
MISINTERPRETATIONS OF THE PENAL
CODE STATUTES OR HOW HE CRIMES
OR HOW EIGHT INCIDENTS ARE
DIFFERENT FROM ONE ANOTHER IS
CRITICAL TO FIGURING OUT. YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT WE'RE GONNA PUT
OUT THERE SO. SO WE ARE WE ARE
TAKING YOU KNOW OUR RESPONSE
VERY RESPONSIBILITIES SERIOUSLY
AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE- SINCE
THE AUDIT LOOKING AT EASE INTO
THE INDIVIDUAL INCIDENT REPORT
FOR THE HATE CRIMES MISSION.
GOT IT AND THE SUBMISSION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
A UNIFORM. IS A UNIFORM FORMAT
S. FOR ALL THE ALLEY ACE. I
MIGHT STAND WOULD BE AND I
COULD- TO MY COLLEAGUE. THE
YEAH YES THE UNIFORM REPORTING
FOR GOT A AND SO THEN JUST
BASED OFF THE TEST FROM THAN TO
NEED TO TREAT THAT FOR AT MORE
THING OR WHY THINGS UNDER
REPORTED OR NOT REPORTED. I'M
JUST A TRAFFIC OUT THE GAP
RIGHT FROM YOUR OFFICERS ON THE
STREET TO GETTING THE CORRECT
DATA TO US GETTING. CORRECTED
AT THE STATE TO FIGURE OUT YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE BEST
PRACTICES SO YOU KNOW WE- I'M
GLAD WE- PUT IN THE BUDGET FIVE
MORE PEOPLE BUT- ARE THOSE FIVE
PEOPLE BEING AFFECTED WITH THE
DATA THAT WE HAVE AND I'M
TRYING TO. FIGURE THAT GAP OUT
THE AUDIT. TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND BECAUSE
OF WHAT THE AUDIT FOUND IS
WE'VE MADE THESE- MORE LEVELS
OF REVIEW REVIEW MADE THE
IMPROVEMENTS SEND DIGITAL
COPIES OF THE REPORTS TO DOJ-
THE- SO THESE ARE THE- THE
STEPS WE'VE TAKEN SINCE. THE
AUDIT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL DID
THE AUDIT RIGHT SO WE DID
RECEIVE- FIVE POSITIONS AS PART
OF THE FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY AND ON BUDGET- AND SO
THOSE WE HAVE ONE POSITION
THAT'S FILLED THE RESEARCHER
THAT I MENTIONED- AND THEN
THERE'S FOR POSITIONS THAT WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF FILLING.
AND SO OR FOR. RECRUITMENT
EFFORT DID NOT LEAD TO A
SUFFICIENT CAñADA POLL WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE ENGAGING IN A
SECOND ROUND OF RECRUITMENT
BECAUSE AS WE ALL GRAY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
EXCELLENT CANDIDATES FOR THE
FOR THIS POSITION SO. I ONCE
THOSE FOLKS ARE ON BOARD WILL
JUST CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVE OUR DATA COLLECTION AND
TRAINING. EFFORTS. OKAY YEAH
I'M STRANDED AT HOW DO WE THE
OF THE REPORTS TO. FIGURE THIS
OUT SO THERE IS RIGHT THERE IS
THE TRAINING THAT WE'RE DOING
ON TO ELEAZAR TO DIRECTLY TO
ELEAZAR ABOUT. THIS IS HOW YOU
IDENTIFY AND REPORT HE CRIMES-
AND THEN THERE WAS ON IT SO
THAT'S- I GUESS MAYBE AT THE
FRONT END AND THEN ON THE BACK
AND- FOR EACH- PRIME. THAT'S
REPORTED TO US WE LOOK AT THE
UNDERLYING INCIDENT REPORT TO
SEE IF IT'S BEING ACCURATELY-
ACCURATELY COATED AND
IDENTIFIED. I MEAN AND THEN OF
COURSE THERE'S THE UNDER
REPORTING THAT'S HAPPENING-
BECAUSE COMMUNITIES- MAY NOT
HAVE THE TRUST AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BUT THEY NEED TO-
AND SO THAT'S- A THAT'S THAT'S
THE ROLE THAT- AN ATTORNEY FROM
DOJ COULD HELP PLAY I MEAN I
THINK. IN PARTS OF THE ERROR
IS. THERE CAN BE. UP. TO EIGHT.
MISUNDERSTANDINGS ARE. WHAT THE-
ARE OF ENGAGING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO FOLKS MAY NOT
KNOW THAT TO CALIFORNIA LAW
PREVENTS. IN A PEOPLE FROM
BEING DEPORTED- AND ENGAGING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THAT.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA LAW
PROTECTS IN A VICTIMS SO. I
THINK HAVING A DOJ ATTORNEY WHO
COULD DO MORE OF THAT WORK-
WITH A HUMAN THE LOOK AT THE
WITH THE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITH THE HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSIONS. WITH THE ADVOCATES
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD GO
A LONG WAY IN INCREASING
REPORTING AT THE COMMUNITY
SIDE. GOT IT. NOW DOES IT MANTA
PLEASE. TELL OUR BECAUSE OF
POLICY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE NUMBERS MAY
NEVER MATCH. TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE. FOR MY DEPARTMENT
EVERY VICTIM OF A VIOLENT CRIME
GETS REPORT NUMBER SO IF YOU
HAVE ONE INCIDENT WITH FIVE
VICTIMS THAT IS FIVE REPORTS.
WHEN I REPORT THAT TO
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT'S
ONE INCIDENT WITH FIVE VICTIMS
SO I'M GOING TO HAVE FOR MORE
THAN THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE ON
MY FINAL NUMBERS AND NAMES
THAT'S THE WAY I'M NOT SURE
WITH- CYBER IS IN. AND DIVERSE
WHEN THAT COMES OUT. HOPEFULLY
NEXT YEAR- IF THAT'S GONNA
CHANGE BUT THAT'S HOW ARE
REPORTING SYSTEM IS NOW SO I
WOULD HOPE WITH SABRES IN A
DATABASE SYSTEM WE COULD BE
ABLE TO. TEASE OUT THAT DATA
EITHER WAY RIGHT. WE COLLECT.
AND WE ALSO COLLECTED IN THE
LEVEL WE ALSO REQUIRE THE
OFFICE LEVEL SO THEY'RE GONNA
WIND AND THEN THAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU GRANT THEN YOU HAVE A
LITTLE BIT DOES LAW OFFICES AND
WE DO REQUIRE ON THE MULTIPLE
VICTIMS AND THE MULTIPLE
OFFENSES BUT IT STILL ACCOUNTS
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT A COUNT
OF HOW MANY HATE CRIME INCIDENT
THAT HAPPENED IN THE STATE.
IT'S AT THAT LEVEL. WHERE THE
NUMBER THAT'S HAPPENED YOU CAN
ALSO LOOK AT THE NUMBER VICTIMS
RAMBLE AND THEN OF OFTEN. WHERE
WE DO WE THAT INFORMATION IS. I
THINK WHAT DETECTIVE WORK WAS
TRYING TO. AND THEN NUMBER AND
HATE CRIMES THAT THEY MIGHT WE
OR BASED ON HOW THEY CLASSIFY
EIGHT BRIAN. THEIR UNIT. IS
THAT THEY'VE DONE ARE YOU DID
AND THEY SHOULD MAKE IT BACK TO
THE DOCKS WORK SCRUBBING SEAT
AND THE NUMBERS COULD BE. BY
THAN THEY'RE NOT IT'S NOT THAT
THEY'RE RECORD FIVE TO LIST
THEIR ACCORDINGLY INCIDENT WITH
BY THE DOZENS BUT COUNT THE US
BY. CORRECT WE'RE COUNTY IS ONE
BUT WITH THIS SISTER YOU CAN.
CHOOSE WHICH DATA YOU WANT
RIGHT SO I COULD EITHER GET BY
THE INCIDENCES ARE. BY THE
EVENTS. YOU CAN DO THAT NOW.
YES I HERS WILL ENHANCE THE
CONTEXTUALIZED. GOT IT OKAY GET
ALL RIGHT BY THE THEY'LL BE
INTERESTING FOR THE AUDITOR FOR
TO DO A FOLLOW UP. HOW TO TEASE
OUT THE DATA. WRECKED BECAUSE
THEN YOU KNOW THEN YOU SEE
DIFFERENT TRENDS AND THE
NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY A LOT
DIFFERENT. GRAY AND THEN JUST
ONE MORE QUESTION IF I MAY
MISTER CHIU. FOUR DOJ ONLY WAS
DRIVERS LONG YOU GUYS
IMPLEMENTED ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT YOU KNOW FOUR DOJ DOES IT
REYES LIKE A RED FLAG FOR YOU
GUYS OR DO YOU FOLLOW UPS LIKE
YOU KNOW EARLIER WE ARE
TESTIMONY OF LIKE SIXTEEN
COUNTIES AT IT REPORT ANY
INCIDENCES AND I MEAN THAT'S
GOT A SEEM ODD GIVEN THE TRENDS
EVERYWHERE ELSE AND EVEN
NATIONALLY. LIKE THEN DOES DOJ
JUST A GREAT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
ANSWERS OR DO YOU GUYS JUST SAY
NO THERE'S SOMETHING THAT NEED
SOMETHING IS GOING ON HERE WE
NEED TO GO IN AND ACTUALLY DO
THE OUTREACH OR COME UP WITH
THE BEST PRACTICES FIGURE OUT
HOW WE DO THESE. SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THOSE COUNTIES ARE
IN THOSE SITUATIONS LIKE THAT
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
LINE'S GOING TO FURTHER HELP
CAN YOU YEAH. PLEASE USE THE
MICROPHONE SO WE CAN REPORT.
PART OF THE FOR. IS AGAIN
INTRODUCE YOUR- WITHIN. AGENCY
THAT WE PEOPLE NOW IN OUR
RENDON AT A FOR THE OF TO FOR
JUSTICE CENTER. OF THE FOUR
POSITION DUTIES THAT WERE WERE
PLANNING ON IMPLEMENTING WHEN
THEY'RE HIRED IS DEVELOPING A
COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT OF THE
AGENCY'S SO WILL NOT ONLY BE
LOOKING AT- PRACTICES AND THE-
ANOTHER GENTLEMAN HAD MENTIONED
THE SECOND HERE. DECISION
MAKING PROCESS WHICH WE DO
TRAIN ON WILL BE LOOKING TO SEE
HOW THAT'S IMPLEMENTED WHAT
LEVEL OF STAFF IS PERFORMING
THAT WILL ALSO BE LOOKING AT ON
THE ONES THAT HAVE HAD IS THERE
A REPORT CAN YOU GIVE US A
SAMPLING OF YOUR- ART SO WE CAN
GO THROUGH AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THOSE INCIDENT REPORTS TO SEE
MAYBE THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
REPORTED AS A HATE CRIME AND
WHY ARE YOU NOT DOING THAT. GOT
IT SO THAT THAT'S WHAT THE NEW
POSITIONS THAT WERE JUST RIGHT
THAT'S PART OF OUR NEW AUDIT
PROCESS SENATE BUT YOU'RE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING THIS
INDIVIDUALS CRACKED. SO WE'RE
HOPING TO GET THIS FULL
IMPLEMENTED SOMETIME THIS YEAR
FROM YEAH. THAT'S FINE. OKAY
THANK YOU SORRY MOB MONOPOLY
THE TIME. NO PROBLEM THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I WAS GOING TO
ASK A SIMILAR QUESTION- IN
RESPECT OF THE TIME. OUR TIME
IS HAVE A REAL QUICK QUESTION
FOR THE- U. P. D. BECAUSE I IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS HAVE BEEN
PUSHING FOR A BILL. TO HAVE A
TO A HOUSE THE CHECK BOX IN THE
INITIAL REPORTING THE INCIDENT
REPORT. TO AND IDENTIFY WHAT IS
THIS- HATE RELATED. CRIME YOU
KNOW I KNOW THE LAPD HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THAT- THAT THAT CHECK
BALK. AND ASSUME TENSING WITH
HIS HOUSE HE PD. I WAS JUST
CURIOUS TO KNOW DO YOU DO YOU
FIND THAT EFFECTIVE FOR
DESSERTS DO YOU SEE. THE THEIR
MORE ACCURATE OR THE INCREASE
OF- REPORTING OFF TO HATE
CRIME. WAS A CHECK BOX. WE THE
COMBINATION. THAT THE CHOI
BOXES ON THE FACE OF THE REPORT
AND SO THAT ASSIST THE DATA
ENTRY FOLKS. ON CORRECTLY
ENTERING THE DATA BUT USING THE
CHECK BOX IN COMBINATION WITH A
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT HAS. VERY
MUCH HELP THEIR OFFICERS
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE NOT SURE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT WITH THE
QUESTIONS OF. WHAT THE
MOTIVATION WAS OF THE VICTIMS
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTIC THE
REMINDERS OF THE ELEMENTS OF A
HATE CRIME THAT THEY CAN JUST
READ OFF AND ASKED TO THE
VICTIM. IS HELPED A LOT A IN
MORE ACCURATELY- CLASSIFIED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
REMEMBER ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS
READ. IT WILL TRIGGER THE CURSE
OF A MENTAL REPORTING. YES BY
GREAT ARI GOLD SO. IN USE IN
WITH IN COMBINATION WITH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL YES RIGHT I MEAN A
MY BILL WAS TO SAY ONCE YOU
CHECK THAT BOX AND YOU HOW
OBLIGATED TO FILL UP THIS
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT FILL. THE
pAGAIN THIS YEAR AND- OUR-
BEFORE WE MOVED TO- TO PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD ALSO WANTED TO-
SANK THE POST I MEAN WELL I HAD
THE BILL TRUE AND TRYING TO-
TRAIN. THE TO TAKE EMERGENCY OR
WOULD YOU CALL OF THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY OF. RESPONDED NO TO THE-
DISPATCHER. ON STAGE THEY ARE
CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING
THE BILL WILL GO OUT BE TOLD BY
THE OWNER BUT I'M GONNA FAN TO
POSE FOR BLOWN EARLY- COME UP
WITH THE SHORT VERSION. OF THIS
I'D HE TRAINING. FOR DISPATCH
THANKS VERY MUCH. THIS. HI
COULD PLEASE SAID AS YOUR NAME
AND YOUR OF PHILLY. I'M GOING
TO WITH THE ARCHITECT THE
STATE'S ALL IS A LARGE
ORGANIZATION SIR PEOPLE WITHIN
THE LAW AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES UP TO ONE OF THE
THANK- BOTH HUMANS TO MISTER
CELIS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IT'S
THE IT'S MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
THE STATE THANK YOU. THE UP IS
IT SIR RIGHT TO CONCENTRATE ON
ON THE- HATE CRIMES AGAINST-
AFRICAN AMERICANS JEWS MUSLIMS
SIKHS. OF LATINOS ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS. IMMIGRANTS L. G. B.
T. PEOPLE UP BUT THE- HATE
CRIMES AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE THE INVISIBLE
HATE CRIMES THEY DON'T SHOW UP
IN THE CYSTIC STATISTICS THE US
DOJ IN- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ESTIMATED FORTY THOUSAND ANTI
DISABILITY HATE CRIMES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. FOUR
THOUSAND THAT SAME YEAR.
ACTUALLY THE NEXT YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE- FBI STATISTICS
BASED ON REPORTS OF POLICE
AGENCIES POUND HOT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY. FORTY THOUSAND
ESTIMATED IS PROBABLY THE AND
THE REST OF IT HUNDRED SEVENTY
ACTUALLY REPORTED. IT'S A IT'S
A IT'S A AWFUL SITUATION UP
PART OF SOLVING THAT AND PART
OF SOLVING THE WHOLE PROBLEM OF
A CRIMES IS UP. POLICE TRAINING
AND POLICE FOREIGN POLICIES THE
A SOCIOLOGIST FOR A LONG TIME
AND HAD THE CONCEPT OF THE LAW
ON THE BOOKS AND ALONG THE
STREETS OF LAW IT. LAW OF THE
LEGISLATURE PASSES LAW THE
OFFICERS ACTUALLY CARRY OUT
MORE RECENTLY THEY'VE COME UP
WITH THE CONCEPT OF THE LAW IN
BETWEEN. HOW HOW ART OFFICERS.
WHAT THE HELL TO GET ARE
ACTUALLY GOT AT THE TWO LA OF
IT ARE. TRAINING CONTROL
POLICY. MR TING TWO YEARS AGO.
PASSED A BILL TO EXPAND THE
FORMAL- FORMAL POLICIES THAT
ARE IMPORTED INTO HAVE POSED AS
A TURN AND IS REPORTED IS HAS
DEVELOPED A GOOD- MODEL POLICY
THAT DOES THAT. YEAH WE HAVE NO
IDEA HOW MANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE ADOPTED THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO ONE TRACKING AT
THE START I CAN TELL. LEAVE THE
UP I WANT TO SECOND A PROFESSOR
LEVIN'S REQUEST FOR YOUR HELP
IN GETTING RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNOR FIVE MONTHS AGO FIVE
MONTHS AGO SEVENTEEN SO RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS WROTE THE
GOVERNOR ASKING HIM FOR AMONG
OTHER THINGS TO ASK THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO ADOPT
THE FOR THE POST POLICY PRETTY
REASONABLE REQUEST AND ORDER
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO ADOPT THE POLICY WHICH IS
REQUIRED BY STATUTE FIFTY MONTH
PARTY FIVE MONTHS LATER WE
RECEIVED NO RESPONSE I HI ADMIT
TO BEING. STRAIGHT IF YOU COULD
USE YOUR INPUT IS LEGISLATOR TO
TRY TO CONVINCE THE GOVERNOR TO
AT LEAST RESPOND TO THE
SEVENTEEN TILL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MADE THIS
REQUEST WE WOULD BE VERY. VERY
GRATEFUL. THE FIRST LEGISLATION
GOES EUROPE YOUR BILL SUPPOSED
TO ARE ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL- I
THINK EVERYTHING IT'S KIND OF
EMBARRASSING THAT WE LOOK AT
THE RESULTS OF THE AUDIT- AND
THE AUDITOR REPORTS THAT ALL
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT MADE ALL
THAT THEY MADE A RECOMMENDATION
TO HAVE MADE UP SOME SOME
PUBLIC TO PROGRESS TO MEET
THEM. OF THE LEGISLATURE- I
THINK IF YOU CAN TRY AGAIN TO
GET FULLER AND ACTUALLY IN IN
ACT ALL OF THE- RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE OTHER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WILL THE NEXT
WEEK THANK YOU ALL UC AND I'M
ADVOCATE FOR TRANSGENDER WOMAN
AND GIVEN THE TIME CONSTRAINT
I'D LIKE YOUR PERMISSION TO
AUGMENT. IT WITH A BRIEF LATER.
BASICALLY THE MAIN POINTS I'D
LIKE TO MAKE AT THIS TIME ARE
MY COMMUNITY FACES
INSTITUTIONALIZED HATE. FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS IT'S
BEEN ILLEGAL FOR A TRANS WOMAN
TO BE IN PUBLIC THE LAWS
ACTUALLY READ. NO PERSON SHALL
APPEAR IN PUBLIC WEARING THE
DRESS NOT ASSIGNED TO THEIR
SEX. THE STATE LIBRARY SAYS
THOSE LAWS ARE STILL ON AFFECT
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN. THAT
MEANS LAW ENFORCEMENT DOESN'T
GIVE A ABOUT MY COMMUNITY THEY
DON'T COUNT AS AND THEY JUST
KILLED AB SIX FIFTY THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. THAT SAID
MY LIFE'S NOT WORTH THE CHECK
MARK. SO IF A TRANS WOMAN IS
KILLED. BY LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY
ARE RACES IN MISS GENDERS AND
THEIR REPORTS IF THEY COME UPON
A CRIME WHERE WE'VE BEEN KILLED
THEY ARE RACES AND MISTER
ANDERSON REPORT. WE DON'T SET
IT ANY OF THESE TABLES DOJ
POSE. ANY OF THESE TABLES
THERE'S NOT A TRANS WOMAN THERE
EVEN THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
CLAIM TO ADVOCATE FOR. I
THERE'S NOT ONE TRANS WOMAN
THAT'S EVER COME UP HERE AND
ADVOCATED AYE I SWEAR. I'M THE
ONLY ONE. IN IT WE DON'T HAVE A
VOICE AND WE DON'T HAVE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE THERE'S NOT ONE
TRANS WOMAN EVEN EMPLOYED IN
THIS CAPITAL. THERE'S NOT ONE
TRANS WOMAN EMPLOYED IT'S THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE. SANTA CLARA
CLAIMS TO BE THE LEADER THEY'VE
GOT TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. THEY HAVE TO TRANS
WOMEN THAT THEY HIRED FROM
SOMEPLACE ELSE THEY HAVE AN
ADDED A DROP. SO MY PLEA TO YOU
IS ONE ITS ECONOMIC. THAT LET
US HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE LET
US HAVE A- EMPLOYMENT STOP THIS
LEGACY OF THE INSTITUTIONALIZED
HATE WHERE WE CAN'T EVEN GO IN
PUBLIC. AND THEN PEOPLE WILL
SEE THAT WERE JUST NORMAL
PEOPLE JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
TRYING TO GET THROUGH LIFE.
THIS THESE LAWS HAVE BEEN
AGAINST EVERY COMMUNITY. THE
CHINESE THE JAPANESE AFRICAN
AMERICANS THE NATIVE AMERICANS.
EVERYBODY HAS GOTTEN OFF THAT
YOKE EXCEPT FOR MY COMMUNITY
AND WE ARE THE LIGHTNING RODS
SO I'D ASK YOU. MOST OF THESE
STUDIES HAVE NOTHING ABOUT
TRANS WOMEN BECAUSE WERE NOT
PEOPLE AND WE'RE NOT COUNTED.
AB SIX FIFTY WAS KILLED THIS
CYCLE. SO WE'RE NOT EVEN A
CHECK MARK AND SO IN THEY LUMP
IT AS TRANS GENDER WHICH MAKES
IT WORTHLESS BECAUSE JUST LIKE
THERE'S MEN AND WOMEN AND THIS
IS THE BIG DIFFERENCE THERE AND
THE TRANS COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION AND TRANS WOMEN
ARE OPPOSITES COMPLETE
OPPOSITES. TRANSMISSIBLE AND
WERE LIGHTNING RODS FOR THE
HATE AND LIKE THE NEXT SPEAKER
IN THE MUSLIM WOMEN WE ARE THE
ONES WHO GET THE BRUNT OF THE
HATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING ALL THE WAY TO
SANTA CLARA. FROM FROM THE CAR
TO SACRAMENTO. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS WHEN SHE
SANG AND I'M A SOCIAL JUSTICE
FELLOW WITH THE SICK COALITION
OUR LARGEST SIX CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION IN THE NATION. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR EFFORTS
TO COMBAT HATE ACROSS OUR
STATE. IN THE WAKE OF THE MOST
RECENT JANUARY THIRTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN HATE CRIME WERE
SICK WE'RE GONNA A HOUSE OF
WORSHIP IN ORANGE AVAIL WAS
VANDALIZED WITH WHITE
NATIONALIST GRAFFITI. I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT LONG STANDING ON
RESULT CHALLENGES. ACCORDING TO
THE SICK COALITION. SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA HAS
THE MOST HATE CRIMES AND
INCIDENTS TARGETING SIX. IN THE
MOST RECENT FBI REPORT
AGGREGATING TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DATA. THE FBI SIDE SIX AS THE
THIRD MOST TARGETED RELIGIOUS
GROUP IN THE NATION. YET NOT A
SINGLE ANTI SICK HATE CRIME IN
THE STATE WAS REPORTED. BY
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY SIX AGENTS
IN THE FBI IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT. IF YOU ARE SICK IN THIS
THE- AND WE SEE THEM IN THE
NEWS ALL THE TIME. AND YET THE
DATA CONTINUES NOT TO BACK THAT
UP. IT IS UNDENIABLE THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE WITH
CORRECTLY IDENTIFYING AND
REPORTING ANTI SICK HATE
CRIMES. BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
ENOUGH ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
THERE SO THEY ARE SERVE TO
PROTECT. WE REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE THE NEXT
NECESSARY CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAINING WITH POST AND ENSURE
THAT ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
SICK COALITION ARE CRITICAL
PART OF ANY HATE CRIME TASK
TRAINING INITIATIVES TO COMBAT
HE- FINALLY. WE REQUEST THAT
LEGISLATORS USE THEIR INFLUENCE
TO REQUEST THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO RESPOND TO THE
SEPTEMBER FIFTH TWENTY NINETEEN
LETTER. CONCERNING HATE CRIMES
THAT CIVIL RIGHTS ALLIES WROTE
WHICH INCLUDES THE DESPERATE
NEED TO INCLUDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS. WHO
POSSESSED THE EXPERTISE IN THIS
AREA TO CREATING SAFER
COMMUNITIES TASK FORCE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
THANK YOU THE NEXT SPEAKER.
OKAY SO WE DO WELL HOW MANY
MORE SPEAKERS WOULD HAVE EIGHT
IN RESPECT OF EVERYBODY'S TIME
CAN LOOK WHY WOULD LOVE TO
LIMITED EACH SPEAKER FOR TWO
MINUTES. THE SCHOOL. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S ERIC HARRIS
SOME WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND THERE ARE THREE
ISSUES THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A DRESS THAT HAVE A DIRECT
IMPACT ON PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. FIRST
INVESTIGATIONS MUST BE THOROUGH
DETERMINING THAT A HATE CRIME
IS DONE WITH THE SPECIFIC
INTENT OF HARMING A PERSON
BECAUSE OF THEIR DISABILITY IS
DIFFICULT. THERE ARE WELL KNOWN
DEROGATORY TERMS AND SYMBOLS
USED AGAINST RACIAL AND
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES THIS IS
NOT ALWAYS THE CASE FOR PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES. IT IS
CRUCIAL FOR IT LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO THINK CRITICALLY WHEN
INVESTIGATING POSSIBLE HATE
CRIMES AGAINST PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. SECOND IT IS ALSO
CRUCIAL FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
BE PROPERLY TRAINED AS. RULES
OF PROTECT THE CLASSES
ESPECIALLY PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND FINALLY.
ABUSE AND NEGLECT INCIDENTS. A
SPECIAL SPECIFICALLY MUST BE
INVESTIGATED PROPERLY. IF
REPORTED THEY CAN OFTEN LEAD TO
MORE SEVERE CRIMES AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND THE ELDER COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN CHIU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATOR
FOR YOUR ALL OF YOUR GUYS HARD
WORK. AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME SERENA ALVAREZ I AM
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
LOOPBACK I AM THE A MEMBER OF
THE STATE BOARD AND DISTRICT
DIRECTOR FOR DISTRICT FOURTEEN
WHICH ENCOMPASSES SANTA CLARA
COUNTY INCLUDES THE CITY OF
GILROY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SALARY ALVAREZ
INSTITUTE FOR NONVIOLENCE ALSO
WE SPECIALIZE IN CONFLICT
RESOLUTION AND PROTRACTED
COMPLEX- I THINK OF THE
AUDITOR. PRESENT REPORTING TO
AND WHAT BIRD. THERE'S A
PERCEPTION OF PROGRESS BEING
MADE BUT THE PROGRESS BEING WE
ARE LEARN WHAT WE DON'T KNOW
AND WHAT BROKEN AND I DON'T
KNOW BELIEVE THAT WE ARE. THE
STATE OF. IT YET I'M COMING
FROM A SANTA CLARA COUNTY SAN
JOSE POLICE DEPARTMENT REPORTED
TWO WEEKS AGO TO OUR CITY
COUNCIL- AT. THAT THEY WERE
GONNA FOCUS ON HATE CRIMES
THOUGH THEY COLLECT HE
INCIDENTS THEY DID NOT REPORT
ON THAT. I REALLY APPRECIATE
OUR REPORT FROM LA P. D. KING
TO HATE AND TRYING TO DEVELOP
MORE INFORMATION. I'D LIKE TO
SEE JUST. A APPROACH LIEU LET
WOULD LIKE TO NOT JUST PURCHASE
ON FOCUSED ON. A Q. SHIP.
INVESTIGATE I. BUT I'M PREVENT
THE ROLE OF FORCE BECAUSE IN
THE KILL SHOOTING WAS. AB IT IN
THE OPINION BLUE LACK. A THE
STATE AND NATIONAL. NATIONALLY
TO A MADE A VOICE ART SAN MAYOR
SAM WITH. IT WILL. THEIR A
VIOLENT. A OUT QUITE WAS
CHRISTIAN MURDERED AND CIVIL TO
TENER PAUL ON AN A TO BE ON
SANK AND SO AND OUR POLICE. TO
PRESIDENT ONE ON FOX NEWS
MULTIPLE TIMES I'M REFERRING TO
UNDER IMMIGRANTS THIS WHO IS A
SUCH AS A MONSTER AND
REDEVELOPING MIGHT SUPREMACIST
NARRATIVE OF OUR BY. AND SO I
WILL THAT'S IT INTO THE- LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOT JUST ABOUT.
REFER INVESTIGATE THEY ARE
LEADERS AND WE NEED LEADERS ARE
SEEN AS A MARILYN THAT. WE THE
POLICE OFFICERS A- AND OUR
CHIEF OF POLICE THAT'S A REALLY
BIG PROBLEM I INVITE THE SELECT
TO COME TO CLARA. AND HAVE A
HEARING WHERE CIVIL RIGHTS
PANEL IS A TO SPEAK MORE THAN
TWO IT'S BECAUSE I THAT OUR
VOICES COLLECT NEED TO BE HEARD.
I'M PROFICIENTLY AND SOUND.
THANK SO MUCH. EXPECT THANK YOU.
MY IS NANCY APPEL OF ANTI
DEFINITELY LEAGUE AND I WANT TO
THANK OF BOTH CHAIR HERE MY
CHIU IN THIS MEMBER FOR YOUR
CAN ATTENTION TO OF AUDIT THIS
IS OF HATE INCOME IT FOR THIS
HE AND FOR THE LEADERSHIP THAT
YOU ARE DEMONSTRATING AND
THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO FOCUS MY
A BRIEF HOLD BE. COMMENT IS
THAT ISSUE LEE. TO SEARCH
EXTENT THE COMMUNICATE. YOU'VE
SHORT SHOWING THE LEADERS BUT
WHAT WE ALSO THINK WE'LL VOTE
AND TERMS OF SENDING BACK THE
MESSAGE TO COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY ARE BEING SUPPORTED TO UP
OFFENDERS AND POTENTIAL
OFFENDERS- AS- WE DON'T KNOW
YOUR TOTAL THAT DETECTIVE
MARTINEZ- MENTIONED IS THE IDEA
THAT I REPRESENT THE GOVERNOR
OR GOVERNOR'S APPROPRIATE
REPRESENTATIVE OR YOU NEED
THAT'S- WILL JUST THIS DOES
HAPPEN. WE WILL PUT BACK ON IT
SO WHEN THE THEY USE THEIR BILL
IT'S TO SAY WE ARE TO COME THIS
AND WE'RE- GOING TO. THIS IS.
THE ON YOUR- IN WHICH A
REPRESENTED HERE THAT SEND THAT
TO MY BACK SO SOME OF WHAT WAS
OF TO. IN THIS LETTER THAT
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE HOW I'M
A RESPONSE TO DOES THAT IS A
LEADER. SOME OF THIS IS
ACTUALLY BEING DONE SO- HELLO
YES HAS NOT FORM AS THE
GOVERNOR'S THEY COMING TASK
FORCE FIRST. OF WILL BE THE END
OF FOR WEINVITED TO BE A OF IT
WILL FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
THAT TASK FORCE MY POSSIBLY BE
TO DO. THAT WILL SEND THE
MESSAGE BUT- IT. BUT NUMBER I
THINK YOU KNOW YOUR CENTER.
FIRST HERE BECAUSE A OF THE
LACK COMMUNICATION SO IF WE'RE
NOT HERE THE CAN YOU. YOU KNOW
FROM. THE GOVERNOR WHOEVER
ABOUT YES WE YOU IN THE IS WHAT
WE'RE- THEN WORK. YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH FAITH AS
POSSIBLE I'M WORTHY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES. SO I JUST
WANTED TO BESIDES I THINK ECHO
IN MUCH. THE BEEN SAID HERE SO
I WON'T WASTE ANYMORE TIME I
JUST WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE BULLY PULPIT
AND LEADERSHIP AND
COMMUNICATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. ASSISTING EVERYBODY
IN THE IN THIS GOING FOR YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEXT
SPEAKERS. A GOOD AFTER MY NAME
IS WILLIAM BURKE AND I'M ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND FOR- THEIR WORK TO
HELP ADDRESS. I HATE CRIMES IN
OUR STATE. HATE CRIMES ARE OF
COURSE PARTICULAR INTEREST TO
THE LGBT COMMUNITY AS MANY
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY TRANS WOMEN
OF COLOR ARE FREQUENT VICTIMS-
AT. TWENTY NINE IN AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE- TRANSGENDER NON
CONFORMING PEOPLE WERE
VIOLENTLY KILLED- AND THAT
NUMBER IS LIKELY TO BE HIGHER.
INCIDENCES CAN'T GO. THIS ARE
ON REPORTED. AND WE WANT
PRECIADO GREETING SAFER FORCED.
ALLOCATE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO IMPLEMENT THE
RESULTS OF THE AUDIT WE WANT
URGE THE ADOPT OF THE- OFFICE.
HE I MODEL PAUL BY ALL OF A LOT.
A AS I THINK FOR THE ARE. TO
AND HAVE OUR VOICES HEARD ON
THIS OR DEATH ISSUE THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK VERY MUCH THE NEXT.
BOB GOOD MORNING MISS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BECAUSE FOR. CHIRLA THE
CO. FOR AND RIGHTS CAL. LARGE
AN ARRAY OUR- DIRECTLY A
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ARE THE
STATE A CALL I GOING MANY OF
THE COMMENTS OF MY CALL. THAT
PREVIEW. I THINK ONE THE
RECOMMEND. REGARDING OUTREACH
IS VERY SIGNIFICANT BARGAIN IS
ATION. EVEN THOUGH I HATE
CRIMES HAVE. AMONG AGAINST
LATINOS HAVE ME INCREASED IN
REPORTING AND THE IMMIGRANT.
HAVE HAVE DECREASED. ARE TO A
BALL FORSMAN AGENCIES HAVE.
REPORTED WE BELIEVE THAT BUT
OUT REACHED. OUT OF PROGRAM TO
IMMIGRANT CAN. AUSPICE IS
NEEDED WE- LIKE SO. WITH LAW.
GIVING DISTRICT. HE ARM AT THE-
JUNIOR WAS REALLY. SLOW JUST
ONES FROM TO CHECK. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT SPEAKER HI I'M A
AND I'M CHRISTI AND WE'RE FROM
THE MIDI I PROJECT ARCH BUT
MANY HIGH. US TO RIGHT I
BECAUSE HE TO FIRST WE LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR US THE TO WHAT
NEXT OF MY THAT'S VERY AND-
ISSUE AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
PROVIDE A IMPORTANT YOUTH ON
THE ISSUE IN IDEAS ON HOW WE
CAN GO PER HAKE WITH AND SCHOOL
X. WE CAN A THE PANTS ITSELF
BEFORE. IT'S AN ISSUE OF BEING
MISREPORTED SO FAR MOST IT'S TO
ADDRESS CRIMES HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE- ORSMAN JUST ACTIONS
ALSO BE STRESSED WHEN A ROOT
CAUSES A THESE CRIMES SUB
CONSCIOUS PREJUDICE OR MORE SO
IMPLICIT BIAS AND WE BELIEVE
THIS CAN BE BACK OMENS THE
EDUCATION CONTENT FOR SUCH A
CRITICISM I ARE MORE IS CULTS
OF. FURTHERMORE THERE ARE OUR
JUNIOR YEAR. THIS WHEN AT LEAST
STATE OWES CLASS HAVE BEEN ONE
OF THE MOST TRANSFORM CLASS
TOWARD MY THINKING MIND SET AT
WHEN I DISCUSS THE RESULT OF MY
PEERS GENERAL CONSENSUS WAS
THAT THOSE SOME OF THE TROOPS
UNVEILED THROUGH THE IMPLICIT
AS UNIT WERE UNCOMFORTABLE.
RICHARD THOUGHT WORD NEEDS TO
BE FACED AND ONES THAT CHAIN
THE WAY WE THANK THAT WAS
SOMETHING ABOUT SUPER IMPORTANT
AND I THE BIASES THAT ARE CLOSE
UP BACK TO. HOWEVER IN THE
TOPIC IS A BY TO THE
CONVERSATION BE LIMITED JUST TO
JUNIOR OR EVEN HOW SCHOOLER. IT
BE SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
BROUGHT TO OLD LEVELS. VIEW
IMPLICIT BIAS CYCLE IN.
EVERYONE HAS. THE MAIN POINT IS
THAT THE ART BORN PREJUDICE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S CALLED
THEIR EXPIRY. AND IN ORDER TO
TRULY ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE OF
HATE CRIMES WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO PREVENT THESE BIASES FROM
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL AND
BECOMING SOMETHING THAT'S RIGHT
MANIFESTED. HATE CRIMES AND
THEN TO DO THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THE CONVERSATION
OF THE ADVISED TO THE DECISION.
FOR BECOMES A NAY THAT BECOMES
OUT OF HAND. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY FOR COMING ALL THE WAY
FROM SANTA CLARA. YOU KNOW AND
YOUR SPECIAL INTERESTS IN THE
HATE CRIME THE OF THE WHOLE
CLASS SHOW UP IN MY LAST
HEARING THE PIZZA SO THANK YOU.
THERE. IS THE SUM OF A HE ON
THE OF THE CAL CHAPTER OF THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN RELATIONS I
MY COLLEAGUE BEFORE ME HAVE
MENTION YOU KNOW THE OVER
ENCOMPASS. MESSAGE COMING FROM
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS- BUT I'D
ALSO LIKE TO- BRING UP- THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW HATE CRIMES
IN IN THE UNITED STATES AND IN
CALIFORNIA- HAVE BEEN SOMETHING
YOU KNOW THAT EXISTED YOU KNOW
LONG BEFORE THE- HEARING TODAY-
MINUTES. THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
NOT ONLY- APPROACHES THAT
INVOLVE LAW ENFORCEMENT THANKS
IF APPROACH READABILITY IT IS
AND- VENTED IF BECAUSE WE SEE
THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR NOT ONLY.
AMONG ADULT WE SEE THEM
CHILDREN. BERMAN TEENAGERS IN
HIGH SCHOOLERS OUR STUDY SHOWED
THAT OVER 40% OF SUBSTANCE.
EXPERIENCE VOTE BASED. EIGHTY
I'M IN IS NOT ONLY LIMITED TO
MOST STUDENTS MANY GROUPS SIX
THESE TYPES OF THIS IN HAITI
BASED ACTIONS INTO A ASIANS
TOWARDS THEM BECAUSE OF THEIR
IDENTITY CITED ENCOURAGE AGAIN-
PREVENT AND REHABILITATIVE A
WHICH THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT-
THE COMMUNITY ORGANIZED IN SO-
YOU KNOW YOU HEAR AT THE
LEGISLATOR OF THE MINES AND
MOUSE PEOPLE- BOAT WE KNOW
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING. ARE THE
EARS AND EYES THAT YOU KNOW SO
ON THE GROUND IN HERE IT'S ON
THE GROUND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH WONDERING HOW. PRESS OF TO
ME HE CLASS IN OUR SEE THEM.
ALL TRICKLING AND NOW SO GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THIS YEAR
AND ALMOST FROM THE MAY PICKS
PROJECT OURS RUN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. AND SO YOUR WHAT
MY FELLOW STUDENTS. WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION IN REFORMING THE WAY
THAT WE REPORT THIS FOR THIS BY
ALLOWING MORE HATE CRIME DATA
TO ACTUALLY REACH THE AYE-
ARMED REPORTING. FBI ANNUAL HE-
REPORTED BY POLICE OF HER
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ONLY LISTS
AROUND FIVE OR SIX THOUSAND-
REPORTS PER YEAR THIS MEANS
THAT MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR. ARE
BEING A REPORT THE POLICE.
BEING VICTIMIZED. BUT IS
REPORTS FEEL. AND THE FBI IS
NOT REPORTS. LAW BECAUSE THE
NUMBER OF REPORTED BY LONG IS A
LOT HIGH THAN THOSE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CALL UP FOR. ACTION
SINCE A LOT REQUIRE US TO
DEPEND DEFECT AND IN ORDER TO
BE PROSECUTED AND SO ON HOWEVER
THIS NUYS THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
AND LEADS TO SKEW STATISTICS
DOES WE EMPHASIZE FOR ALL MORE
OUT. OF THROUGHOUT OF FOR MORE
TRUE REPORTING FOR THIS OF IT
IS SIX BY ACTUALLY EMPHASIZING
THE AMOUNT THAT'S OF.
EMPHASIZED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN A CHANGE THE PENAL CODE-
TWELVE OR THIRTEEN OH. OH
TWENTY THREE AND SECONDARILY
ARE MORE WIDELY PUBLICIZING
SUCH STATISTICS ABOUT THE CRIME
AND THE WHAT INFORMATION IS
BEING COLLECTED WILL ALLOW.
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE ALL ORGANIZATION SUCH
AS ARE PRO PUBLIC OF ACTUALLY
BEEN ABLE TO SHOW THE OPPOSITE
ADVOCACY OF RELEASING SUCH A
MISSION TO THE PUBLIC.
FOLLOWING REPORT ON HE REAL
ISSUES WERE BROUGHT IN. WE NEED
TO HAVE TOUCH A. HI MARIE AND
LETTER TO UP EDUCATIONAL. TO
PLEASE ENTER SECTOR. BETSY TO
BOSS BY OUR- MAKING AT THE
ADMIN SEE WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD DO IN OUR-
TO RACES HER. I'M FOR MEMBERS
OF A AND WERE ARRESTED BUT FOR
THE WITH THE RAW. AND ALL OF
CAL IN THE- RALLY IN TWENTY.
THE PUBLIC NOT ONLY HAS THE
RIGHT TO KNOW BUT IT ALSO HAS
THE ABILITY. TO THE FOREFRONT
AND. I'M ALSO PART OF THE MANY
OUT OF THE PROJECT- I GUESS
TODAY. A SORT OF TOPIC IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
MY PART OF FROM OF MY- FELLOW.
NOT MADE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. MY
PAR PRIMARILY THE INDUSTRY OF
POLICING AS A WHOLE. OFTENTIMES
THE FIELDS AND DISCUSSIONS OF
HATE CRIMES WE ALMOST ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT. RESPOND TO A
CRIMES BUT THIS PROVIDE THEM
SOME. DISTANCE THE ACTUAL
PURPOSE GEN OF HEAT IN THE-
LONG. A POLICE BRUTALITY ON
TARGETING JUST THEM HAVING WAY
TOO MUCH POWER THE POLICE
THEMSELVES BECOME THE ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PERPETRATORS OF
HATE CRIMES. FROM THE MYRIAD OF
KILLINGS OF AND IT'S BLACK
FOLKS TO THE SEXUAL. OF QUEER
FOLK TO TERRACE. COMES PEOPLE
THAT LOOK LIKE ME FACE. THE
POLICE THEM HAVE ALSO BECOME
THE PERPETRATORS OF HATE. AND
ANY DISCUSSION OF HOW TO
MITIGATE HE CRIME WE HAVE TO
START WITH. EVERYTHING AT THE
COUNTER. BE PUT IN CHARGE OF
MAKING US. THIS IS NOT TO SAY
OF. ALL ONE FOR SENATE. THE
RATHER THERE'S GENERAL TREND.
THERE'S A JET TREND OF. BONTA
NEEDS. PERCENT. EVERY TIME I A
CAUGHT A GO DOWN MY SPINE MY
HEAD GOES DOWN WERE MY PIECE
QUICKENS. THE CAN TRUCK THE COP
THAT WILL PROTECT FROM THE BOND
THAT I WOULD BE. I FIRST HAVE
TO TRY THE BEING IN THE- OF.
WILL MAKE ME MORE IN THE FOR
PLACE. LOOK EACH. BE PRETTY
SOME RIGHT WHEN I GO DOWN I
SCHOOL TO GO GET A GLASS ABOVE
A- I CAN BE. BY THE- OF POLICE
IN THE AIR. I CAN HAVE PEACE IN.
ONE TOP A MINUTE IN HE- FROM
THE CRIMES THAT ARE IN OUR OWN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE HI WHERE ARE
PRIYANKA AND WE ARE THE LAST
AND MEDIA FOR. SO AS WE MIGHT
PREVIOUS IN THE HERE THE ISSUE
WITH HATE ISN'T THE PUNCH PRO
BUT SO IN OF MISS BUREAU OF THE
TIMES AND WE FEEL LIKE THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT AS FAR ON FOR AND
INTO THE EDUCATE SPHERE WHICH
IS WHERE I FOR RE. OF THE AS
YOU RIGHTS AND ACT OR FERPA
WHICH DISTORTS DUE TO PRIVACY
LAWS AND IT SAYS DO YOU ARE
ALWAYS TO REPORT VICTOR. I AM.
THE STUDENTS ARE SOUGHT. SHE
RIGHT NEEDS A- SALIM ALI. THIS
MEANT TO PROTECT YOU PRIVATE.
IT BEEN RE MALL. AS A WAY FIRST
TO ALL OUT OF ACCOUNT OF. SO
ALL. STUDENTS FOR BECAUSE IT
LETS SCHOOL OFFICIALS FROM HAVE
THEIR TEST TO SECOND GOT. ONE
EXAMPLE OF FOR BOTH
INSUFFICIENCY IN THIS REGARD
WAS WHEN AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WHEN PUBLIC
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WITH THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT ANOTHER
STUDENTS ONE A NEW SET HIM THE
KNIFE AND CALLED HIM RIGHT BILL
SLURS. WHEN THE STUDENT. AND
LOOK MORE THAT THE SUCH.
APPROPRIATE HANDLED. IN ANOTHER
INSTANCE AFTER THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING THE PUBLIC DEMANDED
ANSWERS WHETHER OR NOT.
APPROPRIATE STATE STEPS WERE
TAKEN TO PREVENT SUCH A TRAGEDY
FROM HELP. AND AGAIN FOR WAS
CITED TO A SCHOOL. TO DODGE
LIABILITY. THUS WE BELIEVE
POLLUTION NEEDS TO BE PASSED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ADDRESSES FOR
BUT OR MORE SPECIFICALLY SEVEN.
NINETY NINE THREE ONE ONE I A
OF THE LAW. THIS ACTION CUT
EXCEPTIONS TO THE PARK SENT-
RULE IN VERBA. FOR THE ISSUE
WITH. TO MAKE ALL THIS IS FOR
DISCO. OPTIONAL FOR SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION. AVAIT NON. SURE
POLLUTION SEE OUR- IT. MAY SURE
THAT WE ARE TAKING ACTIVE LET.
STEPS NOT TO STOP. CRIME AND
FORSMAN BUT ALSO AT THE ROOT
CAUSE. AND WE YOU AS A- FEEL
THE SAME. WE WOULD CHANGE THE
PHRASE TO MUST DISCLOSE AND
THAT IN ITSELF WOULD REDEFINED
THE REST OF THE SECTION TO
ENSURE OPENNESS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. CATION SYSTEM
WHICH PRODUCT VAGUE NOTIONS
THAT MAKE THE SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
ADEQUATE PROTECTING US AS
STUDENTS I REQUIRES A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH WHEN RESTING
SO PERVASIVE PROBLEM. SINCE YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WE- CONSIDER
IT CAN GO DRESSED. ALL RIGHT.
BERMAN AND SHARE ANY OTHER
SPEAKER. PLEASE COME FORWARD
SEEN NONE- I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE PANELISTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO TRAVEL OF FAR TO JOIN
US AND THAT THANK YOU FOR THE-
DICK THE PUBLIC IN YOUR PATIENT
PATIENT FORM OF WHAT WAITING TO
MAKE MAKE YOUR A COMMON HE IS.
YOUR YOUR OTHER'S WILL LOUD
AND CLEAR AND- WAS SHALL I LIKE
TO. A US ASSEMBLY CELESTIAL HE
HAVING CLOSE STATEMENT NOW I
JUST WANT TO THANK ACTUALLY ALL
THE PANELS ON THE OUTER FOR HER
WORK AND THE TEAM EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'VE DONE YOU. HEARD
SOME INTERESTING I CALL. TEST A
AND I APPRECIATE PUBLIC COMMENT
AS WELL BECAUSE YOU KNOW THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
THINGS ARE FOR. SOME OF THE
DECISION TO MOVE FORWARD AND
I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEE WHAT DOING- WITH BETTER
AXES HOW. BORED THERE'S
STRENGTH AND THE ACCURACY OF
THE PERSON HOW WE PRESENT THOSE
NUMBERS- AND SO I AM LOOKING
FOR TO THE NEW DATABASE GOING
AND THE NEW. THE NEW EMPLOYEES
UP HIRING. BUT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I
DON'T UNDERSTANDING WHY THERE'S
AN INCREASE IN ASSAULTS BUT
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE CAN COMBAT
THOSE EFFECTIVELY RIGHT WE OWE
IT DOES LIKE WE HEARD FROM SOME
EVEN PUBLIC COMMENT TINO CAN.
BULLS VIçT BE. THAT ONE THAT
THEY'RE BEING HEARD THAT THOSE
CRIMES- YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
CRIMES AND THAT THAT SOMEONE'S
GOING TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
RIGHT IN BUILDING THAT TRUST IN
YOU THE MORE WE CAN IDENTIFY
THOSE BEST ACTRESS THIS TO
ENSURE THAT. OUR VICTIMS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE A VOICE. THAT
I THINK THAT THE BETTER
COMMUNITIES GOING TO BE AND SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO- THE PROGRESS
AND HOPEFULLY WOULD HAVE TO
WAIT ANOTHER EIGHTEEN MONTHS
BEFORE DOING THIS RIGHT THANK
YOU. TELL HIM ALL YOU HAVE A
FINAL. FOR LOCAL LISTEN. NO I
DON'T TO READ. ORANGE IS WERE
WHERE I'M FROM AND WE HAVE A
ROBUST HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSION SO I- WE SEEM TO GET
REALLY GOOD DATA THERE SO I'LL
BRING ME WAS THE SHINS- BECAUSE
A- PRETTY AGGRESSIVE. IN MAKING
SURE WE GET GOOD AT IT FROM OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ALL OF
FOLLOW UP THANK YOU. WHAT WAS
THAT OUR A JOINT HEARING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING.